in New York City a video has gone viral
a couple videos actually one shows NYPD
questioning a child and asking him for
his vaccine papers please and then they
get removed timcast.com did some digging
and it appears this wasn't a protest
this appears to be just people who live
in the area probably from Jersey who
don't know about what's going on and are
being denied service and the police are
the ones enforcing it in another viral
video there is a man who's been going
around protesting and now you have five
people being arrested at a Burger King
for demanding service refusing to leave
when they're questioned over their their
vaccine passports the police in the
video are saying look you've been warned
you've got to leave and if you don't
leave you will be arrested so here we go
we also have the White House trying to
walk back the statements that Biden made
that there's no federal solution to
what's happening so we're going to talk
about all of this stuff we've got a lot
of news today and joining us today is
Ina stepman how's it going it's going
great thank you you want to introduce
yourself
sure I work for an organization called
The Independent Women's Forum can you
sorry can you pull your mic up trying to
yeah aim it
um so I work for the Independent Women's
forum and very grateful to them for
allowing me to apply for a living
um but I I'm a education policy analyst
cool well thanks for coming
thanks for having me and thanks for the
whiskey oh yeah yeah drinking the good
stuff strong start yeah well uh also I
just wanted to say as people are
commenting yes I I do eat a lot of
cabbage there was an interesting
conversation that happened before this
show started and before we begin I also
want to officially declare that uh Bill
Gates is uh not a scientist and not a
medical doctor why do I want people to
know this random fact no reason no
reason at all and if you want to share
this random fact and help spread to this
very important message you can by of
course getting this t-shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and
supporting me in the process thanks for
having me and this should be a very
interesting show
I'm a very poor replacement for Ian I
can't tell the difference uh yeah Chris
Carr the executive editor at timcast.com
uh please check out our work as often as
possible thanks for having me yeah I'm
happy to switch camera to unsuspecting
people all night
um I am sitting
Sour Patch let's happy to have another
lady on the show as always why are we
working it's limbo week yes the week
after Christmas and to New Year's and
nobody's working you know you're not
even working nope you're awesome pure
fun but you came over anyway yeah uh Man
part of me is just like if everybody
else is not working what am I doing but
you know what we're gonna be working and
we're gonna shout out our awesome
sponsor my friends go to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
your ageless multi-collagen from
BioTrust what is call it collagen you
ask it is a vital protein it's good for
your skin your nails your joints and if
you are an aging Millennial who likes to
exercise and you should be exercising
well I guess regardless of whether no
matter what your age is you should be
taking some well I I would uh I
personally think I'll give the advice
for myself I take this stuff because I
think it's really important especially
as I'm getting older and I skate and I'm
on the half-hipe all the time I want to
make sure my knees are healthy so I take
this ageless multi-collagen from
BioTrust and if you go to stronger bones
and life.com you'll get 51 off and a 6
60-day money-back guarantee the healthy
aging support of college in its ideal
forms five key types of collagen you
need from four different sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits and for every
order today BioTrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kidhungry.org to date BioTrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
Hungry kids please help BioTrust hit
their goal of 6 million meals this year
it is non-GMO and free of artificial
colors flavors preservatives and
sweeteners and free of gluten
antibiotics and rbgh and rbsd nearly no
odor or taste unlike bone broth or other
collagen supplements I gotta be honest
when I mix it in my drinks I don't even
noticed for the most part but does it
adds a little bit like a creamy texture
so it's excellent coffee there's no
clumping you'll get free shipping with
every order free VIP live health and
fitness coaching from BioTrust team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and their free
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
with every order thanks so much to
BioTrust for sponsoring the show these
are the kind of companies y'all should
be supporting because they support us in
the face of just the chaos of the
political climate so again go to
strongerbonesandlife.com to pick that up
don't forget go to timcast.com and
become a member in order to get access
to exclusive members only segments from
the timcast IRL show the show you are
watching we will have a special segment
coming up for members only at 11 PM or
so it's always after the show we record
it so go to timcast.com become a member
and you will see it there around 11 but
also don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends if you really
do like it let's read this first story
we got from timcast.com
enforcement of New York City's vaccine
mandate for children 5 to 11 to eat in
public already appearing on social media
the expanded key to the city guidelines
have now impacted families and the city
and tourists coming to experience the
Big Apple the most notorious video is
this one here where you can see my
favorite thing is turn the volume down
you can see there's a little boy he's
surrounded by NYPD officers who are
demanding his vaccine papers and they
say if you don't have the papers you
can't eat here now
it's it's hard to know to break down
exactly what's happening because it's an
Applebee's and they didn't want to give
us all the details
but we do have this uh let me let me
start from the beginning new uh the rule
expanded Monday to require anyone over
the age of 12 to show proof of a
complete two-dose vaccination a video
circulating on social media Tuesday
Morning appears to depict an NYPD
strategic Response Group attempting to
eject a family from an Applebee's in
Queen Center the family which included
young children did not provide proof of
vaccination
anyone 5 and Up must show a vaccine card
in order to eat here Jose Perez manager
of the Applebee's in the Queen Center
told timcast we have been attacked by
protesters and our staff is on edge and
the police have been helpful while Perez
said he cannot comment on that incident
seen in the video he said that no kids
have protested he added I am tired of
having to answer these questions people
have been calling Non-Stop and we have
work to do here it's very busy well I
wonder if it's just journalists calling
but uh good on the people who are
calling and asking questions now here's
something I think is very important we
have a quote here Christina Myers a host
at Margaritaville Resort in Times Square
said she turned away more than 20
would-be diners by Midway by midday
sorry they can eat outside but who was
going to eat outside with five and
six-year-old kids in this weather
foreigners don't understand why we had
to turn them away even people from Union
City in New Jersey were confused that's
the point that I think is most important
here when I saw that video of that
little kid being you know questioned by
the police I lived in Union City just on
the other side of the river no mandates
as far as I know right now so people are
coming across into Manhattan confused as
to why they're being ejected from these
businesses this is not just foreigners
this mandate means that people in the
greater New York Metro are going to be
impacted by this and I got to tell you I
see a video of cops asking a child for
their papers and uh none too pleased
with it I don't know absolutely they
should be ashamed of themselves
following orders is not an excuse
illegal does not mean it's moral 10 cops
while the city is being plagued with
crime and violence are now going after a
five-year-old because he didn't get
government permission to eat at
Applebee's I mean are you freaking
kidding me this is a new level of
deprived politicization of the police
force of the authorities that are
abusing their powers in order to appease
these benevolent little leaders that are
issuing these decrees that are
absolutely totally backwards and
nonsensical and the details here matter
because at first when I saw that video I
was like oh man why are why are
protesters bringing their kids to this
and and having them interact with police
officers being traumatized in this way
but but the fact that these people
weren't protesters the fact that they
were just there trying to enjoy their
meal interrupted by police officers
saying give me your paperwork or else is
disgusting and I'm sick and tired to see
this happening to a place that I grew up
in destroyed by bureaucrats and
pollutocrats who don't give a damn about
the people
sorry I just had to go on a rant because
that makes me mad so I have I guess the
contrary trick here which is that I
think that it's a positive thing the
police are enforcing this as opposed to
businesses I don't think this changes
until people have a very clear line line
of accountability as to who is actually
responsible for these mandates and what
I actually think the way that the de
Blasio Administration has done this is
really really clever because they have
made the businesses the bad guy
businesses that have been closed
forcibly closed for a year they're
trying to to make back
um an edge in their businesses and they
have been forcibly roped in to enforce
this mandate so when I see police
enforcing this mandate I think that's
the only way this is going to change
because people see those videos the one
we're talking about right now and they
say this is not acceptable but when it's
just a guy at the Applebee's turning you
away well that's not great video and by
the way when when those businesses are
protested like BLM protested a
restaurant that turned away some
customers in the summer those businesses
are trying to stay they like in business
as well they're they're unwilling uh
sort of participants in a mandate that
is coming from the government and
therefore should be enforced by the
government uh and and that's how that is
how like Democratic change happens is
when people actually know who to hold
accountable that's actually a good point
you know when when people see videos and
it's like you're trespassing and it's
like the manager everyone's like well
it's a private business seeing the
police do it well now you've got the
potential the potential potentiality of
the right and the left being like we are
all now mad at the police for doing this
however I kind of think the left is
going to invert their police position
now and they're going to support the
cops for doing this so it's not really
going to have have an impact
ultimately if if the left and the right
both were like okay we're now Angry the
police are doing this I'd be like okay
well you know there you go maybe now the
police will back off and say we're not
going to enforce this but I don't see
that happening I do see the left just
inverting their position because they're
doing they're posting it on Twitter so
as far as I'm concerned I just take the
individualist approach if the government
performs what is what was it the the ash
experiment and the Milgram experiment
was that what it's called Malcolm
Milgram and then the ash experiment was
people willing to deny reality if the
majority told them to so if you have
people who are willing to just deny
reality and then enforce edict because
someone told them to the problem is them
I'll give you I'll give you guys a
really simple uh experiment they did
that's really fascinating they put a
person in a room and they said we're
gonna do we're doing a study here we
want you to fill out this application
the application actually was the study
they put them in a room they had them
fill out the form and they blow smoke
under the door when it was just one
person in the room they see the smoke
they run to the door they feel it they
start yelling there's smoke there's
smoke fire fire
the next the next group they did they
put three people in the room and what
did people do they saw the smoke looked
at the other two people and then just
ignored the smoke so if if you've got
people looking around and seeing no one
taking action it's it solidifies the
problem individuals simply need to step
up and say we won't do it and you'll see
people follow suit I don't think the
left's gonna defend this because the
images are Stark here and they're very
important I mean we're seeing a child
being intimidated by dozens of police
officers this is not just one police
officer enforcing this the NYPD is
bringing out dozens of police officers
men with guns that are going up to
five-year-olds and saying hey give me
your paperwork or you're in trouble
that's that's disgusting and this this
isn't just happening in New York City
this started in Italy it's going on in
Germany it happened in France there's a
picture going around that is depicting
French police officers interrupting the
Matrix movie inside of a theater going
around asking people for their vaccine
mandates for their vaccine passports for
their government permission domestic
passport slip paper to be in a movie
theater to watch a movie I mean imagine
sitting at a movie theater trying to
enjoy a meal and a police officer is
giving me your paperwork coming over
your shoulder breathing over you with
weapons Violent Men being like give me
what I want give me compliance or
interrupting the movie man that's
awesome that's the nature of political
power and I think it's important that
the nature of that political power is
clear and open and on a video that
people can see
um I think frankly not just with regard
to this but with regard to many many
issues the major problem in our
institutions and in our political
culture today is a lack of small D
Democratic accountability and I think
there's a reason they enlisted
businesses to do that it scrambles the
lines of accountability nobody into your
point about people you know being
willing not to comply a lot more people
aren't going to be pissed off and
willing not to comply when they see
five-year-olds being arrested then when
somebody is screaming at the 22 year old
hostess at Applebee's by no means I
totally disagree with both of you
because with the blue pilled normies see
video like that they don't see it the
way that we see it they're gonna look at
that video and they're saying that poor
child has an irresponsible parent that
did not get three shots like I was
conned into getting and now that parent
should be held accountable for not
taking care of their child being a
responsible parent and this is just fun
they wouldn't say conned no no they
wouldn't say that yeah my kid did the
right thing exactly terrible exactly I
don't think there's a lot of people out
there like that I think there's a
perception that there is a lot of those
people out there but I think that's
carefully curated and manipulated I
think a lot of people are saying hey the
first one didn't work the second one
didn't work now the third one's going to
magically work why how where where's the
data where's the science what's going on
here a lot of people have some very
serious questions that the medical
professionals are not answering in this
country and they can't answer those
questions and that's leading to a lot of
people being like hey why are we giving
up our human rights our rights to even
sit alone at a restaurant our rights to
be alone and watch a movie in peace to
to these bureaucrats that aren't keeping
us safe in exchange for this bargain
that we're making with them because
that's the bargain they promised we're
going to give you safety we're going to
give you security just give us your
human rights I would give us your I will
take your dignity risky Freedom over
totalitarian security any day but what's
the end result of this then what
abolished the police everybody in New
York gets mad at cops and says defund
and abolish no I I think this is the end
result of this is when people start to
actually feel the pain of the policies
they have an opportunity this is still a
democratic country they have an
opportunity to change those policies and
I agree with you I think even in New
York City that there are a lot of people
who are let's say not like the folks
around this table but are still they see
that video and they see like this is
going too far this is a problem I think
there are still a lot of people who just
don't pay attention uh to how and and in
what like sort of mechanism this stuff
is being enforced and again when they're
asked by the 22 year old waitress at
Applebee's they don't get mad but when
they see a five-year-old child arrested
by the police or harassed by the police
they do and they start to actually think
about whether or not that law makes
sense I mean this is the the lincolnian
thesis right the best way to get rid of
a bad law is to enforce it strictly
that's a pair of rays he didn't actually
say that but
um but the gist of the speech he gave
was exactly that and he was referencing
um fugitive slave laws right which he
was radically against when he said
actually if these laws are on the books
we should enforce them because that is
that is how people will realize that
this is a bad idea if we selectively
enforce it or we muddy the lines of
accountability we have no way of
actually changing people's minds and
getting rid of stuff like this so I I'm
glad to say the police enforce this
instead of the waitress at Applebee's it
reminds me of that scene from V for
Vendetta when the inspector is like
eventually someone will do something
stupid and it shows the little girl
skipping and she's wearing the the guy
Fox mask so that the cop shoots her and
then all the locals just walk up with
like pipes and crowbars when people
start seeing five-year-old children
being surrounded by cops and quests
having their papers Amanda I agree with
what you were saying you know it's gonna
it's gonna it's gonna set off a lot of
people probably a lot of moms I'd
imagine and that's that's a huge
Powerhouse this is what Steve Bannon was
telling you yes women control the
political landscape what did he say the
French Revolution didn't happen until
the women came out of their houses and
marched and then it was like uh-oh so
when I I think you see these kids there
is a marched like that before the the
Bolshevik Revolution do wow see there
you go that's International
International women's day is a
celebration of that's why it was
originally celebrated by communist
countries it's the the women's working
March yeah you see I think little kids
being surrounded by cops you're getting
a lot of women who are going to be upset
about that not only that but people are
being sent off to camps in Australia
there's police officers walking up to
individuals being like we need to check
your cup we need to make sure that
there's coffee in there because if
there's not you're in trouble what kind
of world did you want to be living in
where where violent thugs with guns come
up to you and demand for you to show
them your coffee because you're walking
down the street are you kidding me
that's not a world I want to live in
that's an absurd world a world that of
course is carefully put into place by
top down Central controllers and this is
what they want this is what they called
for and they're only going to get it if
people consent an acquiesce to it and I
think a lot of people had enough that's
my perspective that's how I think it's
going I think it's important that we
make sure that there are still venues
for people to express that they've had
enough because a lot of not only the
coveted sort of regulations but a lot of
our policy is decided in this country by
unelected bureaucrats and they don't
have any reason to listen to ticked off
parents right
um and and so I think I don't know I
tend to think of a lot of political
problems in this way I I really think
that what we need at this moment and I'm
not always I'm a conservative I'm not
always sort of enthusiastic about small
D democracy I don't think it's always
the the best um you know sort of answer
there is there is a danger of the
tyranny of the majority but I think in
our particular moment we're not in
danger of the tyranny of the majority
we're in danger of the Tyranny unelected
minority essentially we were talking
about this a couple years ago Tim the a
specific study that was done showing how
democracy was a joke and how the major
policies that people wanted were never
passed the policies of special interest
groups were passed showing how
essentially The Works of Congress is
being done by the people who have the
power who have the money the special
interest essentially all of them I
forgot the name of that specific study
there was there was a chart it showed
that uh the that public opinion had a a
zero percent impact on public policy and
that the opinions of wealthy Elites had
a massive impact on public policy that
is what you get when you slow off
political decision making into
bureaucracies yeah right Washington DC
um and to a lesser extent the states but
primarily in Washington DC
um the vast majority of political
decisions are not made by Congress right
this is what was so absurd about AOC for
example being mad that West Virginia has
a powerful Senator
um the reality is the views of Brooklyn
right are reflected much more in an
Elite Class of like a managerial class
of bureaucrats and those people are not
responsible to the majority most of our
political decisions are made either by
bureaucrats or by courts which are
properly placed Beyond Democratic
control but they've gone beyond what
they're supposed to be ruling on between
those two things there's a smaller and
smaller space for the people to express
any kind of opinion or displeasure with
the direction of policy I want to pull
up this story we have here from the hill
Biden says if medical team advises it
he'll issue domestic travel vaccine
requirement now Joe Biden is elected but
this is what you're you were just
talking about how those unelected you
know bureaucrats I think another issue
here is that there's rule by edict so it
with these with these vaccine mandates
in New York it's it's it's an executive
who just says I'm gonna do it without
approval of the courts without the
legislature uh legislative body this is
what we're getting now across the board
people like Biden
threatening domestic travel requirement
or domestic travel vaccine mandates
they're basically saying we're going to
do this anyway and then it will get a
good three months before the courts
actually intervene and do anything about
it so it's rule by decree aside from you
know like the Senate parliamentarian and
other issues we are just continually
getting Governors Mayors and the
president doing whatever they want and
there seems to be no recourse or
opportunity for a redress of grievances
fauci just came out and said it the
other night he was just like look if it
basically gets more people vaccinated
then it's a good thing at the end of the
day yeah he admitted the the mandates
are just kind of of a way to manipulate
people to get vaccinated totally against
the Nuremberg code exactly instantly but
he said it out loud
it's a mechanism it's not for your
safety it's not for your health it's not
for your well-being it's not for you to
look out it's for you to buy a product
not not a violation of the neuroma code
no no no no no that's not true
the Nuremberg code that people are
referring to states that you have to
consent to participate in a trial study
and so the argument is that because
they're still doing long-term trials on
the vaccine no one no one's consent
you're literally literally consenting to
it I understand the vaccine mandates
basically are coercing people into doing
it so that's that's the gray area I just
want to clarify suppose
when you have an emergency use author's
authorization for a vaccine it's not in
the same territory as putting a human
being in a laboratory setting and then
you know what I mean that's what I'm
trying to clarify well the argument that
I heard is that coercion is a strike
against that because if you're coercing
people to participate in that kind of
environment then it's also against the
Nuremberg code because that is coercion
yeah if you can't travel and you have to
get this Force shot then that's coercion
to participate in a medical experiment
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna go
ahead and say uh I stand correct on that
one you know why first I'm not a lawyer
so I can't tell you what if it actually
does violate the number of code but I'm
going to walk that back and and just say
actually you know what that's a that's a
good point the issue is that people uh
so long as there is Phase I think it's
phase two what what phase are we on
they're doing long-term trials right now
actually says this on the FDA insert
phase two I believe we're in right now
so now we've done phase yeah yeah we're
past that so phase one is safety phase
two is efficacy yeah those were the
trials that have been completed with a
hundred thousand people or more the the
the FDA insert for the Pfizer vaccine
says long-term studies are still being
done so you're going to get people on
the left saying it's eua authorized it's
already gone through the safety trials
so it doesn't qualify in that capacity
people on the right are saying well as
long as they are doing studies on it I I
actually I don't know man I kind of lean
towards I don't think I think it's a bit
hyperbolic to say it violates the
Nuremberg code
yeah I don't know man this is all it's
look I'll put it this way the the hype
we are we are polarized we are
completely polarized there's there's
different world views on what what is
happening
I'll just put it this way the left will
say it's eua authorized the studies have
said it safe therefore and the right's
going to be like they're they're not
they haven't finished long-term studies
therefore well the New York Times came
out with a bombshell article today
talking about how some scientists are
warning that too many shots could lead
to people's uh bodies not being able to
fight off covet that's not me saying it
that's the New York Times that literally
wrote a piece about this which which
again is breaking The Narrative of what
we were previously told and and and
believed to by the medical let me let me
just advisors pull that one up just to
show you we New York Times is struggling
to load and the byline is specifically
the most important part here
um that people really need to to read
and to think about especially in the
context of everything that we were told
it says other experts argued that not
enough was known about the effects of a
fourth shot and some scientists have
raised concerns that too many shots
might cause a sort of immune system
fatigue compromising the body's ability
to fight the virus particularly among
older people this is the New York Times
reporting so I want to wrap it back up
to what you were saying about Nuremberg
if we don't know
and they're already a point are at the
point where several countries have said
a fourth shot from you know compromised
I mean now I think you're getting into
you're talking you're starting to get a
dangerous territory over what what over
what you're going to mandate people uh
get so the okay so from my understanding
from what I've just learned about the
Nuremberg argument part of the argument
is based on the definition of coercion
is that not correct from that's what
I've heard yeah so if you're gonna say
that you can't oh you can't travel you
can't shop you can't go to you know the
gym you can't go to movies that sounds
like coercion to me but you I guess you
would have to look up the definition and
make sure that you're arguing on the
same terms I think you could literally
if if that was the definition of you
would you would be able to apply that to
virtually like any approved drug that's
interesting I I I don't think the
exactly this kind of article right in
the New York Times this is assuming that
people are adults and that they're that
this is a novel virus that there are
risks involved with it that like this is
treating people as adults and the
problem is that a lot of our Public
Health institutions have not given
people straight information they have
given people a narrative to try to
manipulate them into behaving the way
that they want at any given time and
that that way changes right we saw like
the the changes over time with regard to
Max masks right um with regard to a
thousand other issues I think that the
problem is that we have not treated
people as adults and sure some people
are irresponsible but that that's kind
of the price of freedom in this country
is that there are you know people get to
behave irresponsibly sometimes
um but I I think the problem is we have
not treated again we have not treated
American citizens as adults we've been
treated as pawns to try to like
influence people instead of just saying
straight out here's the information we
have it may change because this is a new
virus
um this is you know here's the
recommendations that we're giving
because you know we are studying this as
experts and scientists but the problem
is the entire premise of trust for the
expertise and and that entire class of
of quote unquote experts and managerial
class is shot
you know let's just be really I just
want to add to you it wasn't a pun they
haven't they haven't leveled with us
they haven't came out to hey we don't
know the data we don't know in the
information we're still collecting it
this is the informed consent that you
guys are taking here there's also it's
and it's surprising to see the New York
Times Release this article because it is
it is important there are a lot of
implications with those statements and
there's also a New York Times editor
that died recently of a heart attack
that a lot of people have questions
surrounding so so this could be kind of
you know potentially in the New York
Times deciding to ask more questions
after dealing with stuff yeah but but
look
we use mainstream news sources in a lot
of our reporting and I'll I'll all the
information that we have saved like
project Veritas is despised by the media
but I trust uh project Veritas but
almost I would say every single article
we use Save like one or two is newsguard
certified you know established press and
and the information we get that that
talks about this stuff it always comes
from these sources you know when we we
get an article about people being
arrested in Burger King by NYPD it's
it's the New York Post when we get
stories about Hunter Biden it's coming
from the New York Post we got a story
about
um a Ukrainian Court saying that
ukrainians were meddling in the election
and that was the New York Times that
wrote that you've got to weed through
the garbage from these sources but my
point is like you can find those the
like the news and this and and we we use
it so I don't wanna I don't I'm just
trying to say like I'm not surprised the
New York Times wrote about this you know
it just depends on who's writing about
it I guess but here's what I do I do
want to say
you know we're talking about the
Nuremberg cone stuff and I feel like
that's a d that's that's probably a
derailment we don't even we don't even
need to bring that up we don't need to
argue about whether or not it's a
violation of some long-standing you know
code or law what matters is coercing
people into a medical practice is wrong
period I don't care for what reason I
believe that if if you walk up to
somebody and you can see they got a
swollen knee and you're like you know
what this person needs they need
Methylprednisolone is that what is that
what they would give for us for a
methylprednose alone yeah what is that
I'm not sure I think it's Oxycontin
they're probably going to give you the
auditory steroid no I don't know uh
Google it for me yeah all right if if
you see somebody and you're like you've
got a swollen joint and you need some
kind of steroid to to you know
anti-inflammatory uh for this and they
say no I say okay
yeah yep that that treats uh
inflammation severe allergies players of
chronic illnesses and many other medical
problems you see I was correct you're
correct so if I go to somebody who's got
like a busted knee and I say you know
you should like the doctor prescribes it
not me take this methylprednisolone and
they say I choose not to well then they
can say okay but if you go nah your
knees busted no food for you no movies
no restaurants no flying okay that's
where it's like let's not get into the
Weeds on the the weird murky political
stuff about Nuremberg or whatever
because we can just outright say it
don't coerce people into taking
medications or if you're obese like
imagine if you're obese or have an STD
imagine implementing the same
restrictions on individuals for those
lifestyle choices I mean yeah Society
like that sorry go ahead no no so to me
I think the distinction then has to be
and I don't think you can avoid the
whole discussion that way because the
distinction has to be things that injure
yourself versus others right and now
especially in the last several months
it's become very very clear that
vaccinated people can pass this virus
and to me that makes the argument for
the other side much much weaker because
it at the end of the day I'm I'm very
Pro vaccine I have my vaccines but I
think that at the end of the day if it's
not reducing transmission by any
substantial degree anymore then it
becomes about it's like it's like a you
know you're only hurting yourself you're
only taking your chances yourself it's
no longer an aspect of actually
affecting anyone else because it seems
very very clear at this point that you
are not preventing other people from
getting coveted by being vaccinated what
you're doing is making a decision about
your own risk which is ultimately an
individual decision they would have to
say testing mandates because if you get
vaccinated and you can still get it and
people are like you were saying before
the show that people in New York all
have Omicron like it's it's
record-breaking there's like 50 000
cases or whatever and it's bad I mean
you saying people are like let flat in
their back like man I'm sick yeah I mean
it's like a bad flu I mean I I just got
over it
um I I caught it at a dinner party
um happy birthday to me it was my dinner
uh you know all seven people there were
vaccinated every single person was
exposed the only person who didn't catch
it fortunately or at least only had this
nipples one person who was the most
medically fragile so I'm really really
glad uh that he did not but everybody
else like everybody else got sick it's
very very clear that this is not
stopping it so there's no justification
now there's there has to be I think
there has to be some balance between if
you're affecting other people this is
sort of the negotiation of a liberal
democracy how much you know the
negotiation between the individual and
and the common good happens
um but there is no negotiation anymore
to my mind if you if you are not
reducing uh the the infection rate in
the general population by being
vaccinated there is no argument we've
been hearing a bit in the media that
it's uh milder and there's been there
was one story one viral story saying
it's like runny noses but you were
saying it's actually worse than that
like Luke brought it up earlier he said
it's like it's like mild and then you
said well I had friends who had it who
just described it as the kind of runny
nose just like a clo like a cold but
that's my experiences your experiences
are of course different yeah I that's
not what I've seen in New York City
um but I I think
yeah like like flu like bad flu most
people I know who caught it it's a week
or two in bed you know high fever uh
feeling miserable this is just anecdotal
though I don't you know I can't right
right I can't like I just I I just
thought that was interesting yeah
because uh before the show you know Luke
had mentioned it every anecdotal story
I've heard on like Twitter is like these
people are saying I'm triple vaxxed and
I was floored by this and then I see
people posting you know images from news
stories where it's like it's not that
bad it's mild or whatever I I I look I
don't know what we had I I'm assuming we
had Delta when it came here worst
sickness I've ever had do you know I
didn't feel like I didn't think I was
like my life was on the verge of dying I
thought I'd be in the hospital to be
honest though yeah you were in a very
serious situation yeah you were bad as
well
um I was taking different stuff but
that's a different story do you know do
you know if your friends uh were
specifically tested for a variant or do
they know which I mean at the time it's
pretty clear what's circulating in New
York City
um it's and it's also the fact that
there was still some transmission
protection with Delta
um and the fact that like every person
that it has uh either two or three shots
is catching this makes it seem much more
likely that it's Omicron well yeah well
New York City is one of the most
vaccinated places in the world and on
December 26th they had almost 25 percent
of all cases in the United States
presented and in South Africa there's
also a lot of preliminary data
suggesting that this new omnicron
variant is getting rid of the Delta
variant and is creating a lot of people
to have natural immunity and then a lot
of people are reporting that South
Africa is on up and up right now and
that they have reduced a lot of
hospitalizations a lot of admissions a
lot of debts have fallen off completely
in that country I think we're going to
see
a spike in the next few weeks in
hospitalizations even if it's much
milder which I actually do believe
um you know I think some of the data the
data from South Africa is not
particularly helpful for the United
States because we are older fatter and
we have a totally different percentage
of vaccinated people in the in the so
yeah very little value right very little
vaccination so the data that's coming in
from the UK I think is probably more
relevant to us
um and and there seems to be good reason
to think this is substantially milder
and it's resulting in a smaller
percentage of people going to the
hospital or dying but a smaller
percentage of a very very large number
if you are having 20 000 cases recorded
a day which means that the actual
caseload is much higher than that right
you're still going to see probably an
increase in hospitalizations I hope not
but I I think I think you're right
though I think after this a lot of
people will have natural immunity which
is something that is for some reason
only America doesn't talk about natural
immunity European countries consider
like it's part of the policy calculation
is rail keeps it as part of the policy
calculation there's there's no reason
other than bias and ideology as far as I
can tell that natural immunity is not
part of the conversation no talking
about early treatment as well which is
ridiculous we all heard Joe Biden the
other day say there was no federal
solution to this and I mentioned that
that was a massive statement I saw
people tweeting saying oh Joe Biden's
giving up and I'm like no no it's bigger
than that because he's basically saying
everything they're pushing at the
federal level is not going to be a
solution to the problem and now we have
the story
now get rid of your mandates Joe Ron
DeSantis office joins Christy gnome and
a host of Republicans demanding Biden
get rid of useless sweeping Nationwide
rules after he admitted there was no
federal solution for coven you know when
you look at Florida and they have some
of the lowest case rates uh in the in
the country cases of covid it's been
going up and then you look at say New
York or California or Illinois when you
take a look at the mass Exodus from
States it's clear the economy is being
destroyed in these states that are
locking down like like crazy and it's
not it doesn't appear to be affecting
the rate of transmission in fact the
lockdowns may have actually made things
worse we saw this last year I can't
believe it's been two years of this last
year when they said being confined
indoors with recirculated air could
potentially put you at risk it was it
was that's why people going out and
protesting or whatever they said were
less likely to get it because they're
outside well if Joe Biden is is it
really meant it there's no federal
solution DeSantis gnome and all the
Republicans are right and we should end
all these Federal uh policies absolutely
well that's the that's the American
system so in terms of of uh previous
pandemics serious pandemics now we've
been lucky that since the Spanish Flu
there's only been in 1957
um a not as bad a pandemic but we've
been lucky essentially that we haven't
had a major Global pandemic which is I
realize redundant but
um but so if you go back and look at for
example yellow fever pandemics um
outbreaks in in the early United States
there are some very heavy-handed
responses to that but they were all
state and local so like for example
there was a barrier set up between New
York City
um and Philadelphia because yellow fever
was was uh you know spreading so
aggressively people got turned out of
their homes and their property was
burned because that's how they thought
the yellow fever was spreading so our
system gives a lot of latitude to the
states that's that's you know I think
that's a good thing that it gives a lot
a lot to the States but there is no
basis for a federal response and
furthermore it's not just sort of old
letter of the law Constitution it makes
sense the rules for New York City
especially early in a pandemic when we
knew very little have to be different
where you run into you know 200 people
just walking down the street it makes
absolutely no sense to apply those same
rules in Montana it's the United States
is a huge and diverse country and that's
why our system of federalism I think is
a good thing exactly in dealing with the
pandemic so I guess I agree with Joe
Biden there is no federal solution well
we have this from the daily wire White
House rushes to walk back Biden's
admission of no federal solution to
covid19. damn I thought I was going to
agree with Joe Biden folks on Monday
despite his earlier promises to shut
down the virus Joe Biden informed the
governors there was no federal solution
after his reversal of one of his key
campaign promises sparked a huge
backlash the White House quickly moved
to walk back his acknowledgment on that
policy on Twitter the White House
attempted to laud the support provided
to state governments by the Biden
Administration quote the bias Biden
Harris Administration I don't know if I
do this is making sure states have what
they need to tackle covid including a
thousand additional doctors and nurses
stockpiling millions of gowns gloves
masks and ventilators adding vaccine and
booster capacity the White House tweeted
and more
well I I think you can interpret it that
way they're trying to they're trying to
walk it back a little bit because I
think when Joe Biden said there's no
federal solution a lot of people took it
to say it was the White Flag like they
were giving up and now they're like no
no no we're still doing something we're
still doing something but I think the
cat's out of the bag the moment Joe
Biden said that he basically said
fauci's ideas domestic travel bans
mandates whatever
irrelevant yeah but what are they doing
they're like hey we're gonna give people
gloves that's a federal like what are
you doing no federal at all no no no no
no if you really want to do something
you know there's a lot of things you
could be doing especially when it comes
to building up people's terrains helping
people uh you know have proper immune
systems talking about diet talking about
exercise proper sleep getting rid of
stress stopping the fear-mongering
there's a lot of things that that they
could be doing but obviously that their
only bottom line is we have a product
you got to take this product and that to
me is ridiculous and to see them kind of
backtrack with this in this kind of lame
attempt uh just shows you how how
fragile this Administration is how
susceptible it is to criticism and and
how absolutely weak it is it should
absolutely be a state's issue and we saw
the different states approach this
differently Florida did a lot of things
differently than New York did and a lot
of people argue socio-economically and
also medically Florida made absolutely
the Right Moves and I think the more we
decent realize power and authority the
better off we're going to be the people
will have much more choices and the
people are going to be represented a lot
better than the federal top-down
bureaucracy which obviously prioritizes
a product over everything else but the
data proves it just real quick sorry
sure and we'll get into this in a second
but people are fleeing California and
New York and they're going to Florida
and Texas absolutely because that's the
state issues because their economies are
open they have economic opportunities
they don't have restrictions they don't
have mandates they don't ruin people's
lives in the name of selling a product
let's just call a Spate of spade here
well on that subject more people left
California than went to Florida and I
think it was like over 200 000 people
went to Florida
um but in that moment did Biden pivot to
Trump in April 2020 when he was
basically just like we're going to leave
it up to the states I think Trump said
that I think what he said is that uh I'm
gonna give them the flexibility to deal
with this pandemic the way they see fit
yeah well the media pillared before of
course for merely stating the fact that
we live in a federalist system and most
of the decision with regard to police
power which includes the power
um to deal with pandemics are done on
the state level in America they
absolutely pilloring him for that well
first Trump did the two weeks to slow
the spread then he was like okay uh the
states got this and and that should have
been the approach from the version Trump
was actually like we don't have the
authority to mandate these things to
shut down these states it's going to be
up to the governors and the problem with
that you know you know this this pissed
me off is that we had multiple Governors
kill a bunch of elderly in their nursing
homes there's talk of settlements now
lawsuits over the elderly people uh
Cuomo being the greatest example but it
wasn't just him Michigan New Jersey
that's right did California do it too
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania New Jersey New
Jersey yeah Cuomo knew he was warned if
you put these recovering people who have
quote from who had covet and they still
they're still infectious in the nursing
homes he will kill people he did it
anyway that's what happens when you
leave it up to the states and the
federal government does nothing at the
very least I can understand Trump being
like I can't force the states to do
something but he certainly could have
sent in the doj or someone when they
killed a bunch of old people and he
didn't do that either that was like what
was that March or or may was when when
Cuomo was doing this March and April
um look I I this was slightly
conspiratorial but probably not for this
crowd um I think that the reason that
Cuomo was forced out of office over
mostly minor metoo charges is because if
he was forced out of office over this
Scandal it implicate it implicates a
bunch of other Democratic Governors who
all made that same decision
um so I I think it was just very
inconvenient for the Democratic party to
have that investigation continue so they
threw him under the bus and I'm no like
sort of Cuomo whatever booster
um but I think that this a lot of the
charges are either minor or
um I think you know that frankly I'm not
sure about they happened right so I I
just think that's probably why he was
forced out because otherwise they would
have to actually talk about the fact
that these policies weren't just in New
York I do love how Cuomo put out that
video montage of him grabbing a bunch of
people being like there's people who are
really mad that I grabbed them I grab
everybody and it's like he's grabbing
people's heads so it's a combination of
things that are minor right I would
consider the minor like either rude they
might deserve a man might deserve to get
slapped in the face or a drink in the
face for some of the things that he did
but they aren't assault and then there
are only one or two of the charges that
rise to any level of seriousness and
those are the ones I have the most outs
about that man was a monster but there
was definitely something bigger when it
comes to the overblown accusations and
charges that the corporate media went
after him but didn't those accusations
come out like right around the time
people were calling out the killing of
the old people like the story just has
shifted into the me too stuff right on
the hill yeah actually buried the the
the the murders I I was really convinced
uh by a friend of mine's Theory uh that
the Republicans should when they were
impeaching when they when Cuomo was not
going to resign and they were drawing up
articles of impeachment the Republicans
uh there were enough of them in the the
assembly in New York to say they will
not vote for impeachment
um even though they're obviously the
opposing party and wanted Cuomo out
unless the nursing harm there was an
article in the impeachment about the
nursing home Scandal uh but of course
they did not do that and Cuomo ended up
they wouldn't have had the Bulls do it
anyway but Cuomo ended up resigning so
that that opportunity was gone but I
think that would have been something
really positive the Republican Party
even the minority could have done in New
York to make sure that it's formally in
the document that this is part of why
we're impeaching Andrew Cuomo
Republicans doing something
hilarious funny
how often do we get these stories where
Joe Biden says something in the White
House panics and then retracts or pulls
back it tries to walk it back
that happens all the time Joe Biden must
be like sitting in his basement watching
you know reruns of who's the boss or
something just totally oblivious to
what's going on in the real world and
they bring him out they give the
teleprompter and that's why he's not
they don't want him answering questions
that's why there was a really funny
moment when he was talking to the Press
they he had a list of the people he was
supposed to call in in what order and
then he actually said something I can't
remember exactly what he said but one of
the journalists asked a different
question he was like I thought you were
going to ask about uh uh oh anyway yeah
because it was it's all it's all a
prescripted it's all pre-written he has
what was it someone saw that he had like
a list of journalists or something with
their heads he had two cards with their
photos and their names and their media
organizations and and the prescripted
questions that they were going to ask
him all of it it's it's it's a show it's
all entertainment yeah it's it's it's
Hollywood for ugly people I want to tell
you my friends the media works it does I
often say that this conflict we're
facing the culture War has to do with
the people who are paying attention and
know what's going on in people who don't
the people who own only watch mainstream
Media or CNN have no idea what's going
on I can sit here and have very
different opinions from you Inez but we
agree on reality to a to a greater
extent and that's why we're probably
having a conversation people like uh
these these Lefty individuals we pulled
up the Twitter bias of say vosh who's a
leftist commentator he consumes 95
leftist sources whereas most people here
on the show it's a it's a balance of
left and right I want to show you this I
saw this on uh on Reddit
r slash political humor they wrote it
finally happened and then there's our
good friend Jeff teardrick who got his
uh who Rose to Fame by responding to
Trump he's a trump reply guy he tweeted
it's finally happened the family of
raccoons that live inside Lauren
bobert's head have completely chewed
through the wires and he's quoting a
tweet from Lauren bobert where she says
it's almost the end of 2021 and I've yet
to see Biden mobilize true International
low depression like he promised what's
the hold up this is fascinating I
tweeted there accidentally mocking Biden
but don't know enough to realize it this
Jeff teardrick guy is think is saying
that the raccoons have chewed through
the wires and Lauren bobert's head
because Lauren bobert quoted Joe Biden
albeit Lauren you were wrong it's
Trinity pressure that's right
but depression right that's what that's
what Joe Biden said and so I I actually
I saw that it was on Reddit it was like
the front page get the thousands of
comments of people being like Oh my God
Lauren bobert is so dumb and I was like
Lauren bobert quoted Joe Biden and
you're calling her dumb and saying
raccoons are eating her brain yo that's
what we think about Joe Biden why won't
they get it because the media didn't
tell them this so the craziest thing is
when you pull up this dude's tweet and
you actually look at people are
responding they're like she's crazy I
agree with bobert binding to be mobile
mobilizing all sorts of made-up words
I'm trending for being stupid again all
of these tweets calling her insane crazy
an idiot a [ __ ] Etc you only need to
replace Lauren bobert's name with Joe
Biden because that's who she was mocking
for sang true and Anana Shabba the
pressure he also said badakaf care I
don't know what that is either
and then here's the best part on Reddit
I'm scrolling through the comments and
I'm like did anyone point out she's
literally mocking Biden they don't
realize someone did they were like
someone said what is this supposed to be
I don't understand finally someone
responded and they said it's from this
video and they linked to a clip of Joe
Biden saying Trinidad chapter pressure
and then all the responses turned into
to make fun of a man with a stutter like
that is just wrong and I'm like you know
what man
there's tribalism and media manipulation
right there because these people don't
know I you can see it if they genuinely
think Biden is sharpened with it and
able to do this job when the dude speaks
gibberish and if you point it out they
think it's you speaking gibberish this
is why I have no anticipation that these
people will be shamed or woken up
literally woken up by watching a child a
child be harassed by police they're
going to Pivot and pivot and pivot until
they're dizzy and they literally don't
know which side it's up and which side's
down or what's up and what you know it I
I have no hope for these people I really
don't this is idiocracy but this is
idiocracy
um how do you call it I was going to say
exemplified uh but tenfold it exploded
exploded
curated and and promoted by of course
the algorithms that make people see this
and and spread this kind of larger
idiocracy to the general public so again
this is not uh I would say a perfect uh
reflection of reality but this is the
crazy car crash examples of reality that
people stop and look at but at the end
of the day this is still a car crash and
to me not a representation of a lot of
people so there are a lot of you know
people totally ignorant not knowing
what's going on
well the numbers back back you up people
are losing faith in all of these
institutions not starting with the media
where it has been low for decades but
but in all of these institutions every
single poll shows that we are losing and
in some ways that's scary right because
we do need some kind of Institutions
um you know so it's as a small C
conservative like that's that's when you
have revolutions that's why when you
have you know a total rejection of of
any kind of order so it's it's
necessarily I think a kind of dangerous
time but I think it's a good thing that
people are losing faith in institutions
that are lying to them
um and and so I I agree with you I think
that there are a lot more people who do
not aren't plugged into the capital and
narrative than it would appear
what what you what we get from this
evidence or I should say data not not
definitive Pro it's data adding to the
fact that many of these people get their
news from memes yeah now look certain
memes can be funny and memes can share
information and memes are a powerful
thing but you don't only get your news
from memes but they do they don't
actually listen to Joe Biden they don't
listen to his speeches we do that's how
we know he fell down he fell up those
stairs that's how he know he said
battlecaf Karen should I shop at a
pressure it's how we know he himself
proclaimed let's go Brandon because we
actually watch and listen to what's
going on in politics same thing is true
with Donald Trump when Trump was
President they didn't watch him they
only got their news from memes and they
believe it and they voted on it and here
we are a country cannot run based on
ignorant people voting for policies
based on each other it's like the blind
leading the blind off a cliff how do you
solve for it I guess we do shows like
this we say hey guys share shows like
this share share these tweets explain to
people make a meme of this and then show
the clip of Joe Biden saying China
pressure those videos where here's here
it's in my head I can see it it's a
video of Joe Biden going shooting on a
shot but a pressure shooting on a shop
at a pressure then it shows Jeff
teardrick's tweet and plays the theme
from Curb Your Enthusiasm or whatever
there you go you got a meme right there
and then people will see it and be like
wow they don't know anything about the
guy they voted for
well I don't think anyone did I I think
they just voted against Donald Trump I
think the corporate media kind of
brought him to the presidency while he
was hiding out in his basement wasn't
even campaigning wasn't even there
shaking hands with all the individuals
he was literally doing really crappy uh
Vlog videos from his basement so truly
this shows you the power of the
corporate media but I think a lot of
people are being disenfranchised by and
and their relationship with big Tech
social media I think is the thing that
is making a lot of people blind but I
think memes are a way of of combating it
I think memes are are awesome I think
they're they're great they're also a
double-edged sword there there's a lot
of disinformation memes out there but
predominantly I think if it wasn't for
memes I think we would be dumbed down
even a lot more uh than if it wasn't for
me memes are good things like making the
videos that debunk this stuff but if
you're only getting your information
from a from like a meme group or from
Reddit right specifically where again
everything's carefully curated and and
they push a vision that they want you to
have
um and again I I was going to talk about
the intelligence agencies and the ties
to them but I don't want to go off that
rant again but but I I think it's fair
to say you know you know this this level
of Idiocracy I I think is is promoted in
in such a way where it looks like it's
the norm I don't think it is uh but but
people believing that it is the norm
makes people more ignorant makes people
copy and mimic that behavior because
they want to fit into what they're
seeing online as what is popular and
that's the trick that's being played on
people I think I think it's a paradox
for these media Outlets though because
the the stronger and more obviously they
spin the narrative the more their
institutional credibility collapses and
that is backed up by like survey after
survey after survey so like I mean
that's why it shows like this probably
get more viewers than most CNN shows
right
um they are going to the more that they
spin that narrative the fewer people are
going to find them incredible I mean I
think that's why now you're shifting so
much to where social media companies are
deciding you know what what isn't it
isn't permissible to post I think that's
a reaction to the success of alternative
media because so many people are tuning
out from a corporate media narrative but
that in itself shows the weakness of of
the current system so you're saying we
shouldn't be believe CNN when they just
named the CIO of Pfizer the CEO of the
year
well I I look I gotta criticize you I
think it's fair to say he's the CEO of
the year I mean look at the profits
they're raking in to secure these kinds
of contracts with no liability you are a
good CEO some people would say he's he's
making a killing
I just they just let's be real I mean is
it is it of all the CEOs who's
guaranteed the most money for their
company it's either going to be him
moderna or Johnson and Johnson right
absolutely more billionaires than any
other industry out there there you go
you don't have to fact check me on this
if I recall the entire intake of money
for the the music industry in the
country is 12 billion dollars a year
okay Pfizer for 2021 is going to rake in
32.5 billion
for this year
that's a lot of power dude and that's a
lot if I tell you this
how would you guys feel how would you
feel if the government mandated people
watched him cast IRL we'd be loaded we'd
be billionaires we got 300 some odd
million people how many 250 working
working age adults is that is it 250
million I think so there should be more
kids than that I guess not okay so all
of those people forced to watch the show
getting 250 million views per night and
all the government has to do is point to
uh uh the long number the law at them
and threaten imprisonment and then we
get all the free money now you it look
you'd be a great CEO to force your
product on people right absolutely well
that's what insurance health insurance
companies exactly exactly under Obama
here yep pesky seat belts insurance
companies lobbied to make us have to
wear seat belts so it lowers their costs
it just really does I I don't know if
that I don't know have any specific
examples of them actually lobbying for
that though but uh that's what I was
told back in Chicago like people were
that's what I was told so it must be
true you know surely do you write it in
a meme no I love how Donald Trump would
always say something outrageous and then
be like when people were giving them
well that's what I was told
how many people are saying many people
are saying uh no when I was younger I
was out people are talking about this
click it or ticket stuff and and what I
was told was that insurance companies
lobbied so that um when accidents
because accidents are going to happen no
matter what insurance companies got to
pay out the medical but if you if you
Lobby for seat belt laws it does reduce
the amount of overall costs on the
Health Care System New Hampshire is one
of the few places in the United States
where there's no mandatory seat belt
laws and they have some of the cheapest
car insurance uh out there in the nation
so they're just because there's that but
again there's there's uh of course
exceptions to the rule there's also some
I don't know about uh sort of who
lobbied for what but there there are a
couple sort of out there studies that I
can't necessarily endorse because I just
don't know enough about the subject but
I have read a couple studies that showed
that
mandating seat belts have made people
more reckless drivers people feel safer
they drive more recklessly so
perfect back loop I I cannot speak to
the veracity of that Luke was mentioning
intelligence agencies and social media
and so we have this story that's been
going around from The Gray Zone this is
written by kit clarenberg and Max
Blumenthal now you can uh absolutely
argue these individuals have their bias
I believe if they have a leftist biased
but this is an interesting story leaked
files expose serious psyops veteran
astroturfing bread tube star to counter
covid restriction critics that is a
mouthful of adline now I don't know if
this is true I'm not familiar with the
gray Zone take it all with a grain of
salt but they write by covertly
recruiting popular YouTube influencer
Abigail Thorne to counter growing
opposition to UK government covert
restrictions Psy Ops Pros are bringing
home the tactics they honed in the
Syrian dirty war leaked documents have
revealed a state-sponsored influence
operation designed to undermine critics
of British of the British government's
coronavirus policies by astroturfing a
prominent founder of the bread tube
click of anti-fascist YouTube
influencers the project aims to conduct
psychological profiling on British
citizens dissenting against policies
such as mandatory vaccination and
lockdowns then leverage the data to
establish a YouTube channel that
portrays these critics as dangerous
super spreaders of disinformation
interesting I was accused of spreading
election disinformation and conspiracies
because one time I retweeted somebody on
Twitter and they happen to have been
wrong
I don't know I don't know about the
veracity of these claims but this is us
looking through if assuming it's all
true a keyhole into what is probably
very very prominent government agencies
intelligence operations psyops it's all
real they're all working on this stuff I
was just going to say that psyops are
real the CIA has knowingly infiltrated
Hollywood the corporate media politics
of course admittedly so why wouldn't you
think they would not be infiltrating the
online space of course they're doing
this and there's this famous journalist
Udo ufkete he's a German journalist who
literally came out and whistleblowed he
was one of the most prominent most
important journalists in all of Germany
and he said the CIA came to me they they
wrote articles in my name and they told
me just to hit publish and I did many
times so the CIO
udo-u-d-o-e-u-d-o you know that's the
first name Olf Ketty u-l-f-k-o-t-t-e
um came out and said hey I was told by
intelligence agencies to regurgitate
these talking points and I did and uh
yeah yeah so we got it we got a
Wikipedia page pulled up so if they're
doing this with corporate media you
think they're not doing this with social
media obviously they are because that's
how they influence a lot of their
policies that they want to Institute
look Wikipedia says he was a conspiracy
theorist yeah so that means everything
is ever claimed is clearly false of
course Wikipedia is always true no
matter what he maintained this according
to Wikipedia has as he maintained that
journalists including himself and
leading newspapers published material
that had been fed to them or bought by
the CIA and other Western intelligence
and propaganda agencies he was an
assistant editor at the German newspaper
Frankfurter Al jemain zeitung
pronouncing that wrong for several years
until 2003 between 97 and his death he
authored a dozen books including a
number with populist themes
perhaps I'll tell you this I don't know
this guy I don't need to trust this guy
if you think intelligence agencies
aren't seating stories you're the
conspiracy theorist I'm sorry you'd have
to be a conspiracy there's to believe
none of that is going on Russia does it
China does it even small countries do it
small countries that we don't think
would be an issue for us they all engage
in these kind of psychological
operations and manipulations and we get
reports on here's the funny thing we get
stories where it's like the CIA said
Iran is engaging in manipulation
campaigns yes why wouldn't the CIA be
doing the exact same thing why wouldn't
any other intelligence agency be doing
the exact exact same thing in the 1970s
there was Congressional hearings with
members of the CIA admitting that they
have agents within all the major top
news organizations a lot of people
attribute this incorrectly to operation
uh Mockingbird uh but that that's a
separate thing that's a separate issue
there was Congressional hearings you
could watch the videos of CIA officials
saying that they have infiltrated the
top echelons of the corporate media and
they are using of course that power of
the corporate media in order to spread
their stories or AKA disinformation but
it's just okay but that's also how like
a bunch of agencies operate anyway I.E
leaks from agencies not just is it and
it's a specific media Outlets the
relationships between you know
bureaucrats and agencies I mean that was
that's always a problem particularly for
Republican administrators Republican
administrations because the bureaucracy
is so overwhelmingly Democrat but
theoretically if somebody like Bernie
Sanders for example were to get in as
president you would have the same
problems because the bureaucracy is is
sort of uh like a technocratic
neoliberal left overwhelmingly but I
don't think that that's unique to the
CIA we're not talking about leaks we're
not talking about leaks we're talking
about CIA agents implanted in the
corporate media I'm saying that they the
stories that you read are also seeded by
people in agencies often in service of
like inter-agency you know dispute right
what they they allow out about the
administration then you know helps them
take down somebody in a sister
organization a sister agency that they
don't like I mean this there's a huge
problem in in the sensuous relationship
between media and bureaucracy let me
tell you how much worse it is you think
it was bad back then that intelligence
agencies could get someone from their
you know division to work in a news
organization infiltrate oh
YouTube Facebook Twitter Tick Tock are
going to make it so incredibly easy for
intelligence agencies to control the
narrative and control the world you have
no idea I'll make it very very simple
for you
all they need do is have access to
YouTube and they simply say we want this
channel to be on the front page done so
when you have a million channels and you
have one guy who's I don't know Alex
Jones talking about uh all of these
crazy things some of which strangely
turned out to be true
they simply say get rid of them and then
he's gone and then you get other
channels they're like this does advance
or at the very least doesn't interfere
with if you are advancing what they want
and pushing the narrative they want all
of a sudden your videos are appearing on
the front page of YouTube you don't work
for anybody you have no Handler you
don't know why see back in the day when
media organizations were few and far
between relative to today
they needed to figure out how to seed
stories so it could be leaks it could be
over it could be liminal it could be
super liminal or it could be subliminal
nowadays they have a million channels to
choose from and all they have to do is
be like buy ads on this channel this
person will make a bunch of money
they'll produce more content and then
we'll tell YouTube to put them on the
front page then the narrative from the
intelligence agencies dominates it's
that simple absolutely and I would argue
that's potentially happening right now
they're putting CNN on the front page
absolutely I don't think it's limited to
intelligence agencies it's my point oh
for sure that it's it's
an operation about how to do business
I mean that's but that's the problem
right that's why we've we've moved so
far in terms of of um there's a ton of
pressure and these companies have a
uniculture right a monoculture for the
most part they they agree on who the bad
guys and the good guys are within the
companies and between the companies and
what you end up having is a type of sort
of cultural collusion that doesn't even
need to be like sort of communicated
right it doesn't need to be
um told most of these companies don't
even need to be told by some like
shadowy official in an Administration
what to do they know who the good guys
and bad guys are
um they know which side of the narrative
they're on and they can Implement that
without having to be told I mean I think
I know we've moved on a little bit from
the vaccine mandates but I think that's
what the the
um Federal mandate was I think it was a
bat signal it's probably going to get
struck down but it was a bat signal to
Corporate America and most of that
enforcement has already happened
right so like it it is a way of getting
completely around the actual Democratic
process of of passing laws and enforcing
them
this is why social media censorship is
such a big deal
because it's very obvious that what they
what they've been doing over the past
decade with the Banning and removal of
certain certain commentators and uh
you know I guess I got to be a little
optimistic on Rumble and their growth
but I'm still worried that's a
short-term solution the the idea of
getting rid of debates Concepts and and
thinking is absolutely absurd to say
that this line of thinking or this line
of questioning is not allowed is God
like Authority that is obviously going
to be abused whether it's in the hands
of Susan wojinski or the CAA it doesn't
matter that's way too much power with
infrastructure and information highways
that were funded by tax dollars with
also intelligence agencies connections
when you look at a lot of the startups a
lot of these organizations these big
Tech organizations they had connections
to intelligence agencies I don't think
that was coincidental I think a lot of
these intelligence agencies saw this
coming and that's why they embedded
within them they're working hand in hand
with them and I think they're using this
to promote this as you mentioned him in
many covert ways where we don't even
realize that they're doing it and it and
it might not even be that as obvious as
it used to be where they had an agent
within the CBS s news they don't have to
do that anymore they just have to
control the algorithm which I think they
have a lot of sway in at the very least
you can take a look at how YouTube
operates and we often have some of our
segments it's very obvious some just are
Shadow bands some aren't we uh that for
a while they had all these channels in
an isolation bubble where they stopped
recommending them to any uh outside
channel so it's like if you were all it
was a clever way to to destroy
anti-establishment opinions if you were
in this group of people they segmented
you away from all the mainstream YouTube
content so no you are no longer
recommended but if you were already
subscribed to these channels you'd be
recommended only those channels then
over time they shrink out those channels
shut some down give them strikes and
then they're gone
and then it pushes to the mainstream
narrative now you go on look this all
you got to do you understand this get a
brand new computer or open a private Tab
and go to youtube.com and look at what
they promote to people now to be honest
it's family friendly stuff they're
trying to make an entertainment Channel
I get it but you are not you will see
leftist political commentary you will
see Jimmy Kimmel making political
commentary about Trump or whatever even
though it's Trump's not the president
but you're not going to get the inverse
CNN CBS all these news outlets will be
put on the front page and then what do
they do well people were disliking them
and it was strange how was this on the
front page if nobody likes it so then
what YouTube what did YouTube do they
got rid of the dislike button
that's how you do that's how you control
the narrative yeah you also go on the
trending page that also tells you a lot
of what ideas and videos are being
promoted to you compared to of course
the actual videos that are getting the
views they don't show you that anymore
they used to that's how they got
everyone hooked in look at the front
page of Reddit also another huge change
that was happening very subtle
not overtly but but I think slowly and
surely it just became an absolute crap
show and they did it by slowly boiling
the water on Reddit and making it more
and more Progressive making it more and
more just absolutely insane as time went
on just like with eBay and the color
yellow which Tim explains a lot where
people didn't like the color yellow but
they slowly changed it and no they
didn't like white the website was yellow
they changed it overnight to White and
everyone complained like ah it hurts I
don't want to see it so they changed it
back and then every day they slowly made
it white until a year later it was white
nobody cared and I think that's also
happening with our kind of Consciousness
and the information that we're getting
from a lot of these big Tech platforms
that are only getting crazier and
crazier and Crazier by the day and I
think that's exemplified with people
getting crazy and also us dealing with a
mental health crisis that we never ever
had before when it came to the onset of
social media yeah the great Jordan
Peterson broke that down in an interview
at some point in time where he was just
like if I shove you you're going to
fight back but what I have to do is just
kind of take an inch towards you and
then another inch another inch and then
before you know it I've pushed you
wherever I've wanted you to go to begin
with without having to take the measure
of shoving you yep I think the most
important thing when you're thinking
about
you know how tech companies and how
social media manipulate what's seen and
what isn't is that we need to build new
networks from scratch and whatever
Reliance anyone has on any of these
networks
um it's it's any of these companies you
have to operate on the assumption that
eventually you'll get banned and you
have to build in advance and think about
it in advance and build these networks a
new and look there there are major
consequences to having a red and blue
everything right ideally we would not
have like a red and blue coffee shop a
red and blue you know server provider
like red and blue internet right um but
I don't see any alternative because
there isn't going to be another line is
moving extremely fast in terms of like
initially of course some of the most
disturbing things that I saw when it
jumps away from social media and into
real life because some people just with
some legitimacy say like okay well you
don't have a right to a Twitter account
you don't have a right to a YouTube
account that's true but when every
Network bans you right every company
bans you there's a certain
um you know inability to get your
message out but even moving beyond that
they have jumped it into IRL right so
where you can't get a bank account maybe
you can't use private Transit like uber
and Lyft right there's obviously a
problem
um and actually I mean this this I get a
lot of a lot of flack for making this
comparison but not on the substance of
it but on the like shape of the problem
it starts to look very much like what
the 1964 Civil Rights Act was put in
place to solve right because the problem
wasn't that one restaurant was not
serving black Americans the problem is
that every restaurant in an entire
geographic area and every hotel and
every service was not willing to serve a
class of Customer because they had a
predetermined cultural agreement that
didn't wasn't you know quote-unquote
traditional antitrust right because
they're not talking to each other saying
we're freezing people out there was a
cultural a monoculture a cultural
agreement not to serve certain customer
the shape of what's Happening Now I
think is is quite similar yeah let's
jump over to the physical manifestation
we have this story from
americanexperiment.org I'm not familiar
with this organization but they do have
a graph showing the change in population
among states and it's a little hard to
read because everything's kind of small
but you can see here California at the
bottom losing 367 299 people New York
352 000 185 followed by Illinois at 122
460 and then Massachusetts at 46 and so
on and so forth you can then see the
states that gain the most population
Florida 220 thousand eight ninety taxes
170 000. the interesting thing is the
people fleeing nuke in California are
actually spreading Out Among many of
these states now I don't think there's a
one-to-one ratio for the most part it
could be that some people are just
leaving the country outright but it's
very obvious isn't it Florida has one of
the biggest cities in the country Miami
but they're seeing population growth so
it's not a city-sized issue Texas it's
one of the biggest states in the union
and they got some of the biggest cities
they're seeing population growth so it's
not that people are fleeing big cities
or blue cities it's that people are
fleeing totalitarian States for freedom
this is a manifestation of everything
we're seeing going on people are voting
with their feet they're saying I'm mad
as hell I can't take it anymore
and they're moving
it's a tough move to be completely
honest especially you know you've got a
family you got to find a new job
but I'll tell you what worries me about
all this maybe worry isn't the right
word maybe maybe I should say
what I noticed is that we are now seeing
that ideological polarization become
geographical polarization
people are going to say no to Newsome
and to how do you say your name hokel
hochul
people are going to play this stuff and
I'm worried about what happens next when
you then have a city that is 99 Democrat
and another city that is 99 Republican
and they're just going to be like y'all
aren't welcome here right they're you're
going to have that social contract you
were mentioning just a moment ago where
one group says we don't serve that other
group of people but now it's at the
state level but it's even happening
between blue States like you were saying
earlier like Union City New Jersey you
can't go into the city like they've been
doing their whole lives because New York
City is essentially saying you're not
welcome here and you're chill your
five-year-old's not welcome here unless
you do what we say and you soon might
not be able to travel to those
particular States right as interstate
travel could be vax mandated soon which
is oh yeah people have been they've been
talking about putting up state borders I
mean they sort of this sort of happened
last year when police have checkpoints
between Connecticut and New York because
they were worried about New Yorkers
fleeing to Connecticut
but it might I I think we actually might
see it happen I mean uh Europe to a
certain degree has had some border
checkpoints but that's because they're
like we're countries not states the U.S
hasn't had that what which amendment
does it that allows freedom of movements
at the 14th
you can freely move between States but
the the right to travel is pulled I
think it's under the 14th Amendment but
yeah it's I I think the essence of this
is one of the Liberties right uh that
the states cannot I wouldn't want to be
in a state like I don't know California
it's a court invented Doctrine the right
to travel but yeah but the thing with
California it's not necessarily just a
totalitarianism although that does play
a role in the thing about Dimension it's
just not being able to afford to live
you literally just can't afford to live
in California right now in in California
it's I think a much longer Trend than in
some of these other places
um in California there's a vicious cycle
where the middle class is being pushed
out it's impossible to live in
California increasingly as a middle
class family as a combination of of uh
sort of economic benefits and detriments
uh California is becoming extremely
polarized between very wealthy people
who can afford the costs and then a
dependent class of poor people who are
dependent on the state and the programs
um that's a much longer term Trend in
California although I'm sure it's
accelerated now now but I'm not sure how
much like for example and it's not
population normed so it's hard hard to
say that California is just a much
bigger State it's a smaller percentage
of people
um you know could could result in a very
big bar graph but my my impression is
that California has faced this problem
for a quite a few number of years even
before covid and particularized on the
middle class which makes the political
situation worse because the middle class
is the Republican base in California so
like the politics are becoming more
unidirectional Extreme as the middle
class is getting pushed out and it's
probably why their borders are wide open
as well so they could fill in the void
a huge tax this is like 10 or 15 years
ago
um they they discuss what would be
wildly unconstitutional but they
discussed essentially a seizure of half
of your assets and when you exit the
state to try to kill yourself from
leaving oh yeah well it was like up to
10 years after you leave they could tax
you it's like good luck sending your tax
agents to my state it's important though
Florida has 21 million people in Calif
has 39 million so California if you were
to normalize you know for population
California is losing a lot of people
relative to what Florida is gaining you
can also take a look at some of these
other states that are smaller like
Mississippi or Maryland when Maryland
loses 19 871 people Maryland doesn't
have that many people relative to
California so you got to understand
population density as well people are
fleeing these blue lockdown States for
non-lockdown States for the most part
not completely but for the most part
DC is very small in comparison even to
all the states so I I would guess that
if you Norm is by population you would
see DC be on par if not beating out New
York and California for fleeing
especially since the the barrier to
leaving in DC is so much lower because
you can just move across the state line
and still keep your job keep your
commute keep your everything DCS 692 000
people
so yeah so we yeah
um I'm not going to plot a calculator
and do the normalization but you know
you get the point I was trying to see
where New Hampshire was on the list but
it has a very small population but it's
gained I think around 13 000 people
that's pretty significant look we we
lived I lived in New York and I told
people I was getting out because I saw
how bad things were getting politically
look where they are now and then I moved
to Jersey and then it was still bad with
the bombings and the in the police
killings moved to South Jersey and then
the riots happened they crossed the
bridge and I said I'm going to Mill
nowhere yeah I moved out of New York
City as well I ca I couldn't handle it I
was like this is absolutely crazy to be
living in there like I don't know how
you have to there well I moved from DC
so there you go all right it's an
improvement it's an improvement um from
a swamp to a rat infested uh
I I love New York City
um despite some of the crazy politics
I've never lived really in a place where
I agreed with the majority of my
neighbors
um but I think in terms of this this
moving and the decisions that people
were making about
um you know geographically becoming more
stratified
I think the real key would be musing
like what you guys are doing right using
that move to build something new to
build those networks because a lot of
these forces are National right if if
everybody moves to West Virginia even if
they don't bring their liberal politics
with them even if it's only
conservatives for example or people who
oppose lockdowns or whatever it is
moving to West Virginia a lot of these
forces are National West Virginia is 20
years behind in terms of being you know
sort of shaped to your point about the
shades of your point about shades of
moving from yellow to white as a
background color you know if if these
moves are losing
I I think that they still control when
you you still have a corporate media
control you have control of your
bureaucracy National bureaucracy you
have control of most of the culturally
producing institutions not the least of
which are the academy and the K-12
schools so for example even in red
States public schools and the district
officials are at least a standard
deviation or two right left of the
population this is why things move
entire States even red States left over
time this is why the left is so freaked
out about the rights assault on critical
race Theory because progressives don't
have children they have yours I remember
who told us that but it's a good point
yeah conservatives have way more kids
than liberals and Liberals are more
likely to abort their children meaning
if you just went by Family you would
have substantially more conservatives in
20 years and the states would be turning
red however the left probably
understanding this has sought to
indoctrinate the children of more
conservative leaning people with
conservatives now figuring out what's
going on with critical race Theory this
complete completely threatens everything
about the left they don't have kids and
I'm not making that stand up I've done a
bunch of Stories on this back in 2000
there were several studies one found
that a couple of them found
conservatives had more kids than
liberals conservatives are having 2.05
replacement levels and liberals were
having like 1.5 meaning they weren't
what do we get today few research
showing that Generation Z is a teeny bit
more conservative for the first time in
a hundred years a generation is a teeny
bit more conservative because it's
always been shifting more Progressive
it's not because kids are you know
getting woke are getting red pilled or
getting woke or whatever it's because
there's more conservative families who
had more conservative kids but if the
the leftists get their way with critical
race Praxis in schools then the kids of
conservatives will become leftists and
they will continue to expand their
ideology I wonder if that shift has to
do with the fact that an increasing
percentage of conservatives are not
sending their kids into public school
but I I mean I I have to lay this one at
the feet of the right um I said I'm a
conservative so on my own sort of tribe
or whatever
um this is the natural result I mean
William F Buckley wrote God man in Yale
70 years ago and exactly none of of the
Republican party's political Capital has
ever been Advanced uh to do a damn thing
about education and this is the result
of Decades of saying oh haha you know
the blue-haired woke kids when they
graduate an impact with the real world
they'll figure out how to make a dollar
and they'll realize all this crazy stuff
that they're doing on campus is just
wacky well of course all those kids now
work in HR departments in Nike and they
work in you know agencies in the federal
government and they work in you know
whatever all the other institutions
media Hollywood right this is this is an
idiotic concept that you can turn over
the entire education system to one side
of the culture war and focus on whether
the taxes are lower or higher like
that's not good I'm in favor of low
taxes but that's not going to matter if
your entire generation we have now a
generation and a half of kids who have
learned even way before critical race
Theory the previous iteration of you
know 1619 that even even the standard
textbooks when I was in high school in
the mid-2000s
um those textbooks are already skewed
left this is not a new problem this is
and I frankly blame the right for it
even more than I blame the left we have
ignored this problem we have put
absolutely zero political Capital into
solving it and we've we've that we're
now reaping the the consequences of that
but even when there is an effort to
create a school like a charter school
let's say that is going to you know not
allow that kind of stuff they ultimately
do get infiltrated by the woke teachers
who do bring on their woke stuff like I
remember talking to a handful of
teachers at a charter school in San
Diego the charter school is thriving it
was doing great and it was only a matter
of time before the teachers came in they
started teaching things that weren't in
the curriculum teachers were called on
it then the teachers started to unionize
and then it became a disaster the grades
dropped and now the schools become kind
of a gang Zone look okay so Charter
Schools or public schools first of all
but this is happening even in private
schools because again you can't allow
ninety percent of kids to go through
what is essentially a political
indoctrination and imagine that that the
rest of society is going to stay neutral
on that so what's happening is because
we allowed this problem to percolate for
for decades and now I mean look I'm
really glad that this is now on the
Republican agenda in a serious way
largely thanks to pissed off parents who
for the first time when they had Zoom
School actually listened to what's being
taught in in their kids social studies
classes right that that I cannot
describe to you how many parents I've
met who are like I had no idea
it was this bad until I actually
listened to what was being taught so in
that sense I think there's a silver
lining if there's a silver lining of the
school closures that have caused so much
Devastation it's that so many parents
have gotten a front seat to how bad the
indoctrination actually is in a way that
it's really hard to convince parents you
know if they read like a news story or
they see a video they say oh like that
happens in that town but that's not
happening in my town yes it is even in
the red States even in deep red counties
it is happening yeah in West Virginia
the school boards were infiltrated by
leftists by I'm not saying this to be
cute or to be hyperbolic actual marxists
who actually talk about Marx and support
Marxist abuse and these West Virginian
parents are alike but we live in West
Virginia it's like well look at a
certain point I think older Millennials
mostly Boomers and Silent generation
they just thought they won they were
like we did it we won America's done and
then they left and then leftists were
like okay let's go run for school board
let's go one for city council let's
start passing these things because
they're all asleep and not paying
attention that is exactly what happened
after the Reagan Revolution right
um the Reagan Revolution essentially
people said okay we
um we have won a bunch of political
victories
but they focused on the political
victories they forgot about the culture
and what actually happened is all of
those 60s and 70s radicals went and
became professors in the universities
they went and became teachers in K-12 to
your point about charter schools and the
the sort of influx it's that there's
this same bunch of Consultants there's
the same bunch of teacher training
certified teacher trainings the
certification itself the schools of
Education are the most left-wing parts
of left-wing universities right
um the there are National this is kind
of my point there are National
institutions involved here and every one
of those National institutions is
co-opted they're all infiltrated they're
all you know bought into this ideology
so if anything moving to a red state if
you're not actively building alternative
institutions to compete that's not
helpful and you can build those
institutions even in a blue state so I'm
not saying like I think it's fine that
people are moving things for a lot of
people it's a great decision it's a
right decision but I think if you're not
if you're sort of moving and becoming
complacent and saying oh I live in a red
State now I don't have to worry about
these crazy you know indoctrinators or
whatever you are wrong you were talking
about the importance of building culture
too though can you build culture in
those places I I was specific in my
words for a reason
um I think culture is the essentially
the product of that right all of those
those institutions and those networks
you always have individualists you
always have people who disagree right I
went through Public School my whole life
um but I I just think that to imagine
that the education system has no impact
on the political environment when those
kids grow up and and go get jobs and and
vote and participate in society is
ludicrous of course it matters that's
why the left cares so much about it well
that's what we're trying to do in West
Virginia you know if you look at the
little chart here West Virginia isn't
one of these states that has seen the
most growth and I think that is perfect
I don't want to look I like Florida and
I like Texas we went to Texas as
students we uh I've lived in Florida
Before It's also two debts I've looked
at property in both it's ridiculously
expensive and you get very a little land
West Virginia in my opinion has the
freedom not as perfect I think Florida
New Hampshire do do a bit better in that
regard but it's got a small a lower
population density an excellent
opportunity to build culture create an
economic space bring more life to this
particular area and these values of the
people who are here second amendment
constitutional carry Freedom Liberty
individualism responsibility all that
stuff I'm for it so we'll build cultural
around that and that will create an
economic Center maybe not the biggest in
the world maybe not the biggest ever but
big enough that will help people with
these positions with these policy
positions uh grow and succeed and have
families to the you also have to harness
the actual so it's not I I'm in total
agreement with everything that you said
but you can't completely forget public
policy in fact West Virginia after
um you know this state was one of the
last holdouts in terms of school choice
private school choice in in the country
because there's a very powerful like the
they're not really unions but the
teachers the teachers unions here
functionally
um have enormous power hour and we're
able to block those bills year after
year after year in the Republican
legislature even right even after the
changeover when all the Democrats
essentially became Republicans here
um but now you have an education savings
account program here you have the
largest education savings account
program in the country in a state where
just a year and a half ago you couldn't
pass a tiny school choice program for
kids with special needs because the the
Dynamics have changed so overwhelmingly
in these debates I think that that's a
really positive sign so it's individual
building networks being building new
institutions but it's also not
forgetting that public policy is an
important tool and we shouldn't you know
cut ourselves off from availing
ourselves of that tool personally I'm a
Florida man at heart I think there's a
big fight that's going to happen in that
purple state where there's a lot that
kind of ways for the future of this
country but also I think another big
victory that that we should kind of talk
about is is more people homeschooling
than ever homeschooling networks also
becoming more prominent people coming
together and saying hey these
institutions have failed us we could
teach our kids on our own uh and and
sharing resources sharing uh
Professionals in the field and and then
being able to to sit at home and
actually raise their children as they
want without any state indoctrination uh
because essentially if you look at
Education Centers I mean one they're
outdated they were created by the
Rockefeller system that was trying to
create literally Factory workers uh it's
nonsensical and a lot of the stuff that
they teach them it's not only just
brainwashing but a lot of it is also
impractical they could be learning real
life skills in the real world if people
take time to homeschool their children
and I think that's one of the best
things you could do in this life by by
helping raise the future of this country
so formally legally there's always a
separation on the usually on the request
of homeschoolers between education
savings account programs and
homeschooling because they don't want
any a lot of people just don't want any
money coming in from the government but
you can build something very similar and
it allows a lot more people to build
something of that way so for example in
Florida where they do have an Esa
program that's pretty well established
you have families building what they
call Micro schools where you just have
10 families who pull their money from
this education savings account program
that sends a portion of estate funds
that they would have spent in the public
school to the family directly and you
see parents actually you know doing
something really amazing that they're
finding other people who who are sort of
like-minded about what education they
want to give their kid and and they're
pooling that money and essentially
creating a small school and that's
that's really what modern homeschooling
oftentimes looks like it's co-ops it's
it's I think a lot of people have an
idea of homeschooling that essentially
hasn't been true since the 90s right
it's very collaborative it's very like
social people say oh like I want my kid
to be socialized modern homeschooling
has a lot of co-ops it has a lot of
um you know sort of groups and
activities where kids from different
homeschooling families get together so
so in terms of practical as opposed to
Legal there's a very sharp legal
distinction but practically I think that
esa's open up something that looks a lot
more like modern homeschooling for a ton
more families yeah and there's been a
lot of attacks against homeschooling and
this larger idea that it's insular that
you're going to be home they're not
going to be socializing that idea is
absolutely lost and absolutely stupid
New Hampshire has a huge network of
homeschoolers and New Hampshire I
believe has one of the highest IQs per
state per capita than almost anywhere
else in the United States so I I think
that speaks true to the effect that
people are having when they're coming
together in areas like New Hampshire
like in Florida and and are saying hey
when it comes to raising a child this is
something that's important that we can't
just leave up to random strangers when
you do that bad things happen and I
think this is why we have such a big
problem in this country because too many
people relied on these institutions that
are corrupted well even if you rely on
somebody else to teach your child the
responsibility is always with the
parents and we've seen we saw that play
out in the Virginia election right where
McAuliffe is literally was straight up
saying parents have no right to to
decide on what their children learn in
public schools which is ludicrous right
um but that's that is the ludicrous
position that you end up with over time
when that cultural memory of parents
being the primary educators of their
children even if they then hire someone
to do the job for them that primary
responsibility still lies with the
parents um and I I'm really I'm hopeful
on this I think I think that parents are
recovering that you know power of
sitting in the driver's seat of their
children's education and not you know
thinking that because there's a bunch of
experts bleeding that you need a PhD uh
you know in child development in order
to teach your kid math like the I think
parents are really like waking up to the
fact that those institutions have seized
a lot of power from parents and that
they're trying they're they're
determined to get it back
well let's go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends because that really
helps out go to timcast.com and become a
member because around 11 pm we will have
that members only segment up for all of
you guys so again smash that like button
let's read some of these super chats we
got Kyle James he says
getting fired over vax with a doctor's
note listen to after the Bomb by Kyle
James on all platforms I want my own
career love you guys hold the line
right on
sorry to hear about you losing your job
man but a lot of people are are bound
from these states so
I hope you uh hope you guys figure it
out the Bob says anime and gaming
conventions are starting up is is the
pop culture team going to attend
requesting shout out for funding my
custody fight winning the case just
costs time and money GoFundMe help fight
for custody of my son Robert well good
luck with your custody hearing my friend
uh I don't know exactly what we're gonna
do with the pop culture team because the
show is new but if you haven't already
you can subscribe to pop culture crisis
the easy way to find it you can actually
go to timcast.com and there's a tab for
it and this is where the crew talks
about movies new shows video games stuff
like that definitely check it out
Robbie Robbie Hammer says meta fellow
Tim cast daily listener at the gym today
had a nice chat and he told me that your
show changed his political philosophy
used to be a leftist keep unplugging
peeps from The Matrix
cool cool right on man um I'm glad to
hear it well the best thing you guys can
do is if you like the show to share it
and tell your friends about it um that's
that's how podcasts grow is that people
play it in front of other people or tell
people to listen to it friends will come
over and they'll be like you know
they'll be chilling with the show in the
background or something like that or in
the car uh I don't know man I also think
it can be kind of like corny like guys
listen to this political show You're
Gonna Love it or maybe that's what you
got to do you know what I mean
all right let's see we got Nova says
rakeda law said he would be happy to
come back Jack also messaged him
basically threatening his ability to
appear on your show bad look for timcast
guests thinking they can ban other
guests uh I have no idea that's all
about Rakata is always welcome to come
back on the show we're big fans and he
does an excellent show and whatever beef
there is between other people nothing to
do with us but uh by all means not cool
if that's the case I haven't seen it but
if I see it then I will absolutely
expand upon it
amateur anth says simpcast IRL we need
to fight for our rights to parte and our
right to life liberty The Pursuit of
Happiness which the government has taken
away since women have have had the right
to vote repeal the 19th
ladies
men voted in the 19th right yep again
it's all men's great observation and uh
women are over are women are more likely
to be pro-life than men that is correct
but the left often makes it's like you
know seem oh it's these men who are
regulating women's bodies like that's
actually the woman vote
I I think one of the to move away from
the extreme case but like I do think
that there are some political
differences between men and women not
just the obvious
um there are more male Republicans there
are more female Democrats
um but I I think women often are sort of
The Gatekeepers of whatever the the sort
of institutional culture or the um the
small see conservative sort of cultural
memory of a place
um and so if if the institutions go
One Direction I think women kind of
preserve that whereas men tend to be
more willing to Buck an institution or
like for example social Arrangement than
women obviously these are
generalizations and there's plenty
plenty of women who Buck those
arrangements and men who don't but um I
think that that's part of the reason
we're seeing women uh vote so much more
Democrat I think it's like alignment of
sort of the the regime and I mean that
in the like Aristotelian sense not like
in the Putin's regime kind of uh way but
um I think women tend to align more with
the regime of a place so more agreeable
all right the Sinister sibling says
things are getting worse here in
Australia they refusing food and produce
from unjabbed farms enhancing a food
shortage there are now attempts by our
state governments to ban the
non-compliant from being able to vote
isn't isn't voting compulsory in
Australia so there's gonna be a lot of
people being like okay good I guess I
don't want to vote in the first place
they make me do it but imagine what it's
going to be like when you allow one
class of people to vote another class
not to it'll be fun yeah
there's nothing slippery about that
slope I have no idea what you're talking
about but but is this not too dissimilar
to service guarantee citizenship sounds
like it the state says provide service
to the state in this case get your your
vaccine and then you can vote and
everyone else can't
so but the the smaller version of this
happened in New York City during the the
city elections um and yes apparently
they cannot under federal law prevent
for example somebody from voting because
they're not wearing a mask
so there were some attempts and some
like just disagreement or but yeah so
that we have fortunately we have some
legal institutions in place in the
United States that will prevent that
from happening at least for some time
all right
der 0694 says heard about Kroger's
mandate on S2 underground's Christmas
update today I got my food at local
store across the highway and will
continue for now good on you we had mark
lobliner on the show and he has the
outright bars which is like a whole food
protein bar and they're delicious
seriously he got us a whole bunch we
ordered some they're so delicious and
he's he wrote a letter to Kroger it was
Kroger right and they also own uh I
think Ralph's we're not going to do
business with you because of your
vaccine policies taking away benefits
from employees and it cost him what he
said seven figures he was willing to
forego millions of dollars to his
business to do what was right that is
exactly what we've been talking about
saying you got to stand up and I'm not
telling people to you know sacrifice
that much money from their business and
I'm I'm even saying I understand a lot
of people might have difficulties but
that is and the the the example of
standing up man I I respect that
tremendously commendable outright bars
man from Tiger Fitness Paulina prochaka
says hi from Poland today I went to ice
ring they had mandate for how many
vaccinated and unvaccinated people could
be on Ice they enforced it
what's going on Luke that's crazy what
is this well Poland's been making a lot
of stances against the European Union uh
very important political moves but
domestically I think internally there's
places like New York City and Poland and
also there's places like Florida in in
Poland but I think majorities like like
Florida from my perspective but you know
everyone has their own rules and uh
however they want to implement it that's
up to them
all right John Kristen's uh Christian
says Mark was an awesome guest last
night would love to see Jim Wendler on
co-founder of elitefts what is that I
don't know I think I'm pronouncing it
right creator of 531 lifting program
Elite power lifter and London Ohio High
School football coach great example of
building culture cool sounds good check
him out yeah
oh what is this
uh fast fur says today is my birthday
and it was pretty crazy so here's money
I meant crap so here's more money well
thank you for your money on your
birthday happy birthday
David trace says anyone who is willing
to demand papers from a child will put
that child on the rail car if ordered to
I completely agree and that's why I
tweeted the quote from Michael malice
when he said there is no law so obscene
that a police officer would not be
willing to enforce it up to and
including executing innocent children
it's a bit of an extreme statement but
uh he did he said it before in reference
to Waco now I get it Waco was federal
law enforcement but I think we
understand his point when ordered to
they fire bombed the house this law
enforcement officers and they killed
many children so uh when I saw that
video of them telling this kid show us
your papers I was like I don't think
Michael's wrong I think the issue is
that they're going to assume they're
being given orders for a just reason
there's going to be a kid running
through the street and they're going to
say stop that kid he's dangerous and
they're going to say okay
and that's it okay I'll get killed
hopefully hopefully we never get to that
point though but I think you see it with
a lot of other countries and what
they've done to assume that it can't
happen here in America I think is
incorrect
Brado Jacko says stop calling people who
don't take a possibly deadly jab
irresponsible nitwits it is
irresponsible well for the sake of of
YouTube I will just say I agree with the
first part of that and unfortunately the
second part of that will probably get us
in trouble to put it simply though it
should just be your choice from your
medical professional professional and
your advice and I actually think someone
who's willing to say I'm going to do the
groundwork to investigate is a smarter
individual
but unfortunately YouTube is an
unfriendly beast that's why we put a lot
of our episodes up on Rumble and we have
all the clips there as well which you
can definitely check out all right
Let's see we got here we got Ryan green
it says everyone should give the
Applebee's in Queen Center a one star
rating on Google hit them in the pockets
I'm not necessarily a big fan of that I
would say if you go there for some
reason do so but I do think you can call
them and ask for a comment and and ask
them questions about you know what's
going on with your policies what are the
exemptions or the medical exemptions I
think regular people need to understand
that there will be social enforcement
the left is really good at this someone
there's that race car driver whose dad
said a naughty word in the 80s and so he
lost his sponsors that guy Brandon Brown
over the let's go Brandon he can't get
sponsors now because nobody he didn't do
anything
it was it was reporters they're really
good at Social enforcement Ryan Long's
new sketch is hilarious where it's a
left-wing and right-wing podcaster
presenting their sponsors and the
left-wing podcast says I don't like that
bunker ties advertises on Patriot
podcast and then it shows the Patriot
podcast going bunker ties will no longer
be advertising with us it's like even
right-wing companies like that whole Hub
of over Black Rifle coffee yeah should
never have happened but
conservative companies and politicians
Republicans care more about the opinion
of the New York Times and their own
constituents and fans yep also this news
did come out we didn't get to it wraith
Customs firearm says Hey crew former
Senate Majority Leader Harry Reid just
died reported 30 minutes ago via all
major mainstream Outlets can we get your
thoughts on him and uh Him Luke
um aliens
he was very big into uh getting
information out about aliens I don't
know too much about him other than that
I don't wish to kind of say anything
else further to be honest with you yeah
I you know
I don't know a whole lot about Harry
Reid to be lilianas because he was
before my time I know that he was into
aliens and stuff like that but for the
sake of someone just died I try to let
you know things simmer down a little bit
literally just happened
all right Steve Van valkenberg if no
independent or conservative Outlets talk
about covet for two weeks or a month
what do you think would happen in the
current state
what do you guys think it's a really
interesting question mm-hmm
I think
one of two things could happen it's
possible that the narrative shifts
completely to something else but
conservatives don't control the news
cycle they typically just respond to it
they don't set it that's how you end up
with Justice Milad of the Covington kids
they responds typically equal fact check
or call it out but it's possible that if
they don't talk about it the leftist
narrative becomes dominant and then they
enact a whole bunch of crazy policies
because there's no pushback yeah or
maybe everyone just forgets about it but
I I think they would just have no
pushback and they push even further I I
could see it going either way not for
the mechanism that you're talking about
but just because I think there's a
certain percentage of historical people
on the left who literally continue to do
things just to prove they're not
Republicans I mean we saw people saying
that about math oh I wear I wear a mask
because people will think I'm a
republican David Hogg said it he was
like but people will think I'm
conservative
Andrew M says I was I was diagnosed with
covet yesterday I could hardly breathe
refer to the ER with BP 180 over 1 4
temperature 103 it is still serious but
possibly milder today I felt I feel okay
and got the mab treatment thank God
treatment is available
me and Ian were really bad man and maybe
Monaco antibodies yeah yeah uh Ian and I
were just like on do we just felt
miserable it was really really awful and
then literally 12 hours after the
monoclonal antibodies I was like I'm
better it was a rough night though no
joke after I was that was the worst
night after I got that that treatment
but the next day I was like wow I still
felt a little sick but it was clearly
gone away crazy crazy yeah I I I I've
always I've always thought we should
take it seriously but the issue is
not to the extent that the the the
Democrats have been doing acting like
the world's ending it's like look it's
really really bad I understand slowing
the curve I understand you know trying
to be take precautions and stuff I also
understand Florida has policies in place
that seem to be working very well so
maybe we should look at where the data
is actually working and not where it's
not
Mr the cool says head PE has a good song
called feel good the lyrics speak to me
more these days when you take time to
listen you understand more
right on
all right let's uh where are we at
Calvin fox says where is the federal
government getting a thousand doctors to
help the states I believe they're
military right that's what I read yeah
sending military doctors
all right
Granite what does it say Granite is
nice I do miss Ian but I've enjoyed
seeing Chris on IRL more can y'all make
them a regular well yeah especially with
Ian popping up through a kind of you
thank you thank you very much for saying
that absolutely
red coat leader only two percent of
patients currently in UK hospitals have
tested positive for coven this is the
lowest for 2021. Boris confirms no new
measures for England despite record test
number the pandemic is over maybe that's
what Luke was saying the other day
you're saying you thought that Omicron
was going to lead to people like giving
up on it I don't know if you agree yes
potentially in a month to three months a
lot of scientists are saying that this
is the best case scenario because it
will build up to natural immunity and
then people will of course end this
official sickness so I think there's a
possibility I think 80 percent chance
from my own personal perspective that
that could happen unless there's another
mutation that is again highly debated
how it comes up and how it's made but
who knows how it will go but I think
from everything I'm seeing it's going to
be over in a month to three months I
don't and add to that fatigue I I think
for slightly annoying reasons um which
is that once all of the reporters in
Brooklyn get those behind them the
country will be able to get it behind
them
and I think you're already seeing the
narrative shift on like at lightning
speed and I think that's what's going to
happen unless as you say if there is
like some major new strain uh that
really changes the equation in some way
but through a combination of vaccinated
and natural immunity now plus the
all-important social factor of the
hipsters in Brooklyn it I think that
last factor is probably more important
than any scientific reason naturally a
new variant coming that's going to be
more lethal and more dangerous is is is
very very very rare and that's why I'm
saying that's the situation that's going
to happen
all right Andy plays game says have you
seen don't look up it's a fascinating
social commentary in the realm of a
comet impact replace Comet with covid
parallels are astounding I didn't see it
I saw like the snippet at the beginning
and I thought it was about climate
change or whatever but you said it was a
good thing I did I liked it and again
it's left up for people's interpretation
you could interpret it as you want but
just just think of it as an asteroid and
it was a good critique of the media the
the critique of of what the corporate
media does was absolutely perfect and I
liked it I enjoyed the movie cool I hate
watched it last night to the better end
uh you didn't like it it's totally
appalling I mean really I mean well yeah
because I mean we the director already
came out as you know like this is all
about him dealing with his own anxiety
about climate change you can also watch
it through the lens of the flip side of
it it's just like it's not common
hysteria it's covet hysteria and I guess
there's some sort of a defanged
political parody in there somewhere but
I I found the movie awful I found the
acting terrible and I thought the ending
was truly offensive wow the ending was
up
it was it was a family-oriented kind of
ending right I would I would that's not
spoil We're Not Gonna name the opposite
really and nothing would make me happier
to spoil it for everyone okay all right
all right I'm gonna have to go watch it
yeah Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim guys
how can I not super chat about Biden
saying let's go Brandon to himself in
real life to himself in real life Inez
how is Biden our leader
don't ask me he's not he's a puppet he
said it to himself that's what killed me
about the mainstream the corporate press
coverage is it like the story was this
guy came in and he said that and that's
just so disrespectful and I was like no
that's not the story the story is that
he repeated it blindly that's the story
I agree I agree let's go Brandon yeah I
think it's really remarkable that
everyone else on that Democratic stage
was so much worse like that's I mean
that's remarkable in itself
it really is man all right Joseph
fencing says we have a habit of
accepting scapegoats and allowing
corrupt structures to persist events in
history where all guilty parties and
their policies are found and removed
take the trophy for being the rare
occurrence the circus is powerful
indeed and more people mentioning that
Harry Reid has passed away the last
thing I saw of him he was talking about
UFOs yeah could he have gotten too close
to the truth no I don't I don't know
about that all right Mr physics says
America is following step four step with
sarist Russia bloated bureaucracy
inevitably stonewalling the government
into extreme incapability to fulfill its
duties there will be a revolution within
the next 20 years well if you believe in
the straws out generational theory that
will be in the next six years
yeah well it should end by 2028 right
yeah that's when the Great conflict is
supposed to end well there you go
Mr Obvious Mr Obvious says Dems need to
stay out of red States they always vote
for the same policies they are running
from they ruin everything they touch
they never learn
there's a viral Twitter thread from a
guy in San Francisco and he's like we
have to move we have to leave San
Francisco the policies here it's
everything's being ruined and we're
going to Miami and of course we
recognize the politics of Miami are
worse it's like no no no no no you're
you're not being honest that you would
not move there if it was worse
that's that's what I'm worried about too
when we see that Exodus how many of
these people that are leaving these blue
states are actually more conservative
leaning or how many are just more
progressives and Democrats are going to
bring those policies to Florida and
Texas
it's a one step even more I think so
when you have companies that move their
seats for example from San Francisco to
Austin
um You're Gonna Change the makeup of the
state because then it won't just be the
people who voluntarily leave some of
whom are still you know sort of liberal
Democrats and leaving for other reasons
um but at least the majority of people
have some skepticism because they're
leaving once you have companies move
their seats to some of these places
it'll they'll just ask their employees
to move out it'll be an indiscriminate
selection of mostly rich people uh in
for example San Francisco and then it'll
get really really bad the political sort
of this is what I was saying about Joe
Rogan moving from California to Texas
you know a lot of there's that comic we
bring up I think it was Ben Garrison
where uh he's walking from California
carrying a bag the bags as liberal
policies and there's a text in being
like hey leave that where you know where
you came from
when Elon Musk moves his headquarters
from California all of those California
employees who are leftist or left laning
are now in Texas and they're now going
to vote so it's not a good thing when
these companies move everyone's like
yeah you show California who's boss and
then they bring all those employees to
Texas and they change the makeup
especially once when it's at risk of
flipping
could be a bad thing
only outside of Austin Austin's a
different story it's a communist City
yeah yeah Gray's really bad woke doctor
says is that or is it woker hey uh Hey
Tim long time fan yeah and you know
water seeks its level eight inches per
mile squared and stuff never go full Ian
what is it what is that I'm confused
yeah does that is that I was thinking
about this when I saw the Super Chat I
was like if you had like a big plane
that was like 100 square miles and you
put like a hundred tons of water in the
middle how deep would it be in the
middle like I don't actually know and
I'm sure there's actually an easy way to
find out but would it be leveled all the
way across or would it be deeper in the
middle because of surface tension it
would be level I would think to any
measurable degree that's why he's saying
eight inches per mile squared is that
what he's talking about or is that some
kind of like hidden code and Ian is
watching he's like I got the message you
got the message
I think I think I think it's something
else that's actually the thing that's
planted by the CIA guy yeah oh yeah it's
an activation code
I actually think what's more likely is
that it's not anything in particular but
Ian thinks it's a code I got the message
there's no message there
steel steel Valor says Tim I wonder what
the political breakdown is of how many
people have died from covid you should
do a study on this I think
um in early on it was blue States and
then it switched but that's just if you
trust the official data coming out like
New York Times or whatever I don't
actually know the numbers I would
imagine it would skew Republican because
older people are more likely to die of
covet so I would imagine it would have
to be a really strong political effect
to overcome the age difference true Eric
Reid says love you guys and appreciate
the show but my goodness please get your
history straight segregation and
anti-miscegenation were state enforced
not cultural interstate commerce clause
in the Constitution bolstered by the
14th uh I have I have many times talked
about my family having to flee certain
States due to anti-miscegenation laws so
we certainly understood and have talked
about how it's state enforced and then
you know you end up with Supreme Court
rulings can I clarify uh so but that was
the debate right the the previous
versions of the Civil Rights Act uh did
not include the public accommodations
clause so the the debate over putting in
the public accommodations Clause was
because uh even when some of those
segregation laws were rolled back on the
state level you still had a massive
cultural agreement among businesses that
functionally continued segregation which
is why the debate over the I should have
clarified not said the whole act but the
public accommodations piece of the Civil
Rights Act which was the the major
difference between the 64 act and and
its previous iterations
Luke you made a move out you're going to
say a word no no no okay all right there
we go Afghan Raven says Tim I just
retired from the NYPD and would love to
discuss why they are acting the way they
are that actually sounds really
interesting
um do you still have spin the UFO I do
spintheufo at gmail.com sure and it's
Afghan Raven LRT okay so see if you can
connect and uh I think you know be cool
to do like a sit-down interview or
something and discuss yeah from a former
police officer yeah and why you retired
and is it have anything to do with
what's going on
all right Ivan Chavez Luke a true
Florida man would have a mullet just
saying
um don't do it good idea no it might
happen I hear them all it's coming back
I could be wrong about that maybe I
think it's only hipsters doing it though
so the mullet is very popular now among
like 22 year old New York there you go
see told you X says it's actually closer
to
truwin and niner
Shava the pressure you keep saying
trunanana Shabba pressure no it's
yeah pressure get it right Shabba oh no
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry he did have the
dot in there oh that's my bad okay uh I
don't know I I sat there and I had it on
Loop and slo-mo and I was like trying to
write it out I worked really hard on
that one because people were saying true
in a little or something like that and
I'm like that's not what he said it's
you know Trinity pressure this is giving
me flashbacks to listening to so much
speaking in tongues when I lived in a
rural Kentucky growing up oh yeah yeah
just like hearing I'm just like I think
I hear I understand some of these words
maybe that's what Biden's doing it's
starting to emerge you know
wow we should be more careful with our
criticisms then yeah
silently in Atlanta says a meme of the
Nativity oh it just jumped on me what
are you doing YouTube they always do
that okay now we'll try and go back and
figure out where that uh there we go a
meme of the of the Nativity says even
though Mary and Joseph had masks The
Innkeeper denied a room since they
didn't have a vac status card Facebook
stamped it with it with an information
resource where to find a vaccine
speechless amazing
Matt fentazi says Tim when can we expect
Frank from quite frankly on his recent
interview with chrisanne Hall was a
major white pill she would be a great
guest as well I know Frank he's a cool
dude um we'll we'll hit him up we'll
figure something out Frank has a podcast
quite frankly I I hung out a couple
years ago at their Studio good dude it's
great I haven't talked to him in a
minute just in passing but we'll we'll
reach out to him
big bad beard says the people of NYC
need to hold the NYPD accountable of
these actions that is the fastest way to
change things I agree but uh what's you
you just moved there what's your view no
I mean that's that was kind of why I
think it's good that the police is doing
it because when it's the business there
is not really anybody to directly hold
accountable that has power over the over
the policy itself so I agree that the
police need to be account held
accountable But ultimately the people
who need to be held accountable are the
people making the political decisions
that are ordering the place to do it
cool
overdressed says pop culture crisis is
really fun to listen to I just listened
to all the episodes on Spotify if you
haven't you should show you should go to
timcast.com and check out pop culture
crisis it is a podcast talking about TV
shows movies
Etc pop culture issues so it's um
sometimes talks about cultural stuff but
mostly pop culture and then we sometimes
talk about pop culture stuff but mostly
culture and politics so that's why we're
like we should do a separate show
because we've got a ton of opinions on
the new movies that are coming out we of
course love all these movies and music
so let's make a show for it and we did
and it's a very uh new channel we're
still working out getting everything
going we just taking it uh slow but if
you want you can go on YouTube and
subscribe to pop culture crisis and uh
we'll start promoting it maybe in a few
weeks but we want to get the ball
rolling and then once it's established
we'll do like a big promo thing for it
for sure
uh Free Speech says Tim why were you
afraid to hold Jack accountable well
I'll say a few things on this for one uh
I I don't know a whole lot about what
went down between Jack and Sydney other
than these clips that were on the
internet I didn't watch the show and it
was a few days after what had happened
so I was like I don't know look you know
we have guests who are booked for the
show I don't know about all the drama
going on in their lives some people
pointed out that fresh and fit had some
drama and they were super chatting us as
well and I'm like yo I don't know
anything about it I'm not here to to
condemn or condone any kind of behavior
I can certainly say I told Jack he
should have apologized outright to
Sydney because he should not have
snapped at her like that and that's all
I can really say I mean holding
accountable require being involved in a
better understanding of what happened so
I definitely feel bad because I I think
Sydney and Elijah are cool people and I
I don't know I don't know man that's all
I can really say about it for the most
part other than I hope everybody can
figure out how to find peace and get
along and we can you know strive to do
better with uh fighting towards Liberty
and freedom and um shout out to Elijah
and [ __ ] neither show as you are here
they do a good job and they're cool
people and I don't know what this talk
is about ricada law or anything like
that rickade is a A rad dude and he's
always welcome on the show as well and
uh I don't know if there's any other
super chats I'll see what I can read
Danny Lincoln says I got offered to film
for Monster Energy pretty much a dream
job I had to turn them down because I
said I need to get the jab that's the
way things are going man it's the way
things are going
all right uh Porter Davidson says did
you guys hear that Kamala Harris said
that democracy is the greatest National
threat I don't think we should give her
the benefit of the doubt that she
misspoke did she really say that I
looked that up so did she say that I'm
not sure yeah well I gotta be honest I'm
not a big fan of
um
the act like democracy on its own you
know what I mean by that is like
Benjamin Franklin said what did he say
he's a a democracy is two wolves and a
lamb deciding what's for lunch and a
republic is a well-armed lamb contesting
the vote
so uh that you when you really I think
most people understand it's probably
even better than I do but when you
really start to read through history and
understand the purpose of the Republic
you're like oh I kind of get that man
smaller States need to have the ability
to defend themselves from larger and
more powerful states otherwise you can't
have a cohesive system that's why we
have a constitutional republic with
Democratic electoral processes there you
go
eight ball says can you truly say a
country is free if you are forced to
vote for a set principles in direct
opposition to your own
well no in the United States you can
vote for whatever you want but there is
a dominant social culture man so
all right let's just read uh one more
we'll read one more here
lamby says won't be long till the death
data will have to be reviewed fed up
with seeing deaths 28 days after a
positive covet test on the BBC UK media
the data cannot be trusted and a review
has to happen I don't know a whole lot
about what's going on in the UK but uh
we definitely need the data and there
was a big controversy because Pfizer
doesn't want to release it until what
like 2050 or something oh yeah yeah well
my friends
smash that like button if you have not
already subscribed to this Channel and
share the show with your friends if you
do like it head over to timcast.com
become a member we will have a members
only segment up around 11 or so p.m just
for you guys you'll see it on the
website timcast.com you can follow the
show at timcastirl or like underscore
IRL whatever we get you know basically
everywhere and you can we have Clips on
Instagram you can follow me at timcast
you guys you want to shout out social
media or anything else sure you can
follow me on Twitter at Inez felter f e
l t s c h e r but if you type in stepman
it'll it'll pop up thank you so much for
coming it was awesome to have you here I
have my own media organization called we
are change you could watch a video I did
today on YouTube and I did another one
about my predictions for the future on
Luke uncensored.com hope to see some of
you guys there thanks for having me
Chris car 17 on Twitter uh oh did I yeah
no sorry I know it's your turn Chris
carr17 on Twitter uh 17 in honor of the
17th letter in the alphabet thank you
and I'm also here in the corner it does
look like Kamala Harris said that
democracy is the biggest national
security threat in a CBS interview which
is really interesting a couple days ago
oh yeah I didn't see that at all slipped
right by me yeah that's terrifying okay
anyway you guys may follow me on Twitter
at Sarah patchlands all right everybody
head over to timcast.com for that
members only segment don't forget to
sign up smash that like button and we'll
see you all there bye guys